man it is uh it's a slow news day andrew
gillum he's not really in the news all
that much but he was indicted on 21
felony corruption charges kind of crazy
story because he was like 0.4
away from being the governor of florida
and then we would not have ron desantis
so crazy story we'll talk a little bit a
little bit about that we got a story
that's got everybody a little bit pissed
off is that 14 republicans
four of them out of the blue
have signed on to red flag law gun
control bs
and now steve scalise is basically going
around being like do not vote on this
when it goes to the floor or whatever
and i can't say i'm surprised the
republicans in my opinion are fairly
garbage but we'll talk about that we
also got ron desantis in many statewide
polls actually leading trump and on
predict it
uh rhonda santos is beating trump to be
the candidate in 2024 and i think the
issue was quite simple
ron desantis is in politics now actively
engaging in the culture war so his star
is rising donald trump is not he's
having rallies but
he's just either stagnant or just you're
there ron desantis has two years of
growth ahead of him so i think it's it's
a fairly good bet we'll talk about this
and we'll talk about fake news and other
issues around that satire because we are
being joined by the ceo of the babylon
bee seth
dillon that's me i'm sorry introduce
yourself that's my cue there my bad ceo
of the babylon b fake news you can trust
yeah fake news you can trust so uh well
so what's the babylon be for those that
might not know
for those that might not know we're like
uh where they call us on our wikipedia
page the conservative version of the
onion i guess that's kind of how we were
known initially in the media um
yeah we uh we exaggerate the truth with
fake stories
um
that often come true because reality is
catching up to satire yeah it's about as
fast as we can right and then what do
you do when you know your satire comes
true do you have to go back and then
like
delete it because it's real news now
like oh uh we we mark it down as a
fulfilled prophecy we're tracking them
in a spreadsheet now i posted a google
doc recently i've got like 67 or
70 of these things
jokes came true well we'll talk about
all that yeah it'll be fun we also got
sheamus seamus coughlin of freedom tunes
here um i am interested in having a
conversation about desantis and trump
that's always a fun one i have a youtube
channel called freedom tunes we just
launched a website freedomteams.com you
guys go over there for five bucks a
month you become a member get an extra
cartoon every week we got a bunch of
cartoons up there now you'll also help
us get independent from big tech over
there check it out i love you i was
trying to remember regards to babylon
who was the guy with all the prophecies
but i don't was he a babylonian guy
wasn't nebuchadnezzar i don't think was
it well well there were a number of
prophets in the old testament but you
know babylon was is a reference to like
the the exile so you had like the hebrew
people in exile and like babylon b is
like a play on that saying that like
we're like conservative christians today
are like doing dispatches from exile
so well let's talk more about that
tonight maybe if it comes up yeah for
sure yeah and i'm over here missing my
cues in the corner because i'm
distracted i'm very sorry you have my
full attention now seth is fantastic
he's very funny i'm really excited for
this evening's conversation before we
get started my friends head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and pick up your
c8 mct oil powder from biotrust their
keto elevate so uh full disclosure since
like november i dropped like 30 pounds
and it's because i cut out the sugars
i've been increasing the fats and
basically just fresh veggies protein
high fat i love putting this stuff in my
coffee in particular as well as a bunch
of heavy cream heavy cream head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com you'll get a
60-day money-back guarantee keto elevate
provides your body only c8 the most
ketogenic mct that means it provides
support for energy levels healthy
appetite management mental clarity and
focus athletic performance
five grams of the highly sought after
mctc8 per scoop keto elevate is my
favorite mct powder on the market i love
that they write that down like i'm
supposed to say but it is true someone
actually did bring in like other mct
stuff and i thought it was actually kind
of bad and i was just like nah we just
need more of this stuff because the keto
stuff the biochar stuff actually is
pretty good
it actually is my favorite
you'll get free shipping on every order
for every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids police help biotrust hit
their goal of 6 million meals this year
you'll get free vip live health and
fitness coaching from biotrust team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order and the free
e-report the top 14 ketogenic foods with
every order of course at
eatrightandfeelwell.com they say 51 off
today so thanks for the support biotrust
don't forget to go to timcast.com
become a member you click that sign up
button the top right and you'll get
access to members only segments of this
show we're gonna have one for you
tonight at 11 p.m it is uncensored and
not family friendly i imagine tonight
would be particularly funny so it'll be
a good time you'll also be supporting
our journalists our anti-big tech
censorship infrastructure we use rumble
so don't forget to smash that like
button as well subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends if
really do like it let's jump to our
first story from not the bee oh
14 gop senators just voted to limit your
right to keep and bear arms including
lindsey graham who said he would
vigorously oppose the bill
well if you trust lindsey graham you've
got other issues going on okay so that's
basically the story uh the senate on
tuesday broke through nearly 30 years of
stalemate on gun control legislation by
voting 64 to 34 to advance an 80-page
gun safety bill to respond to the mass
shootings of buffalo and uvalde that
left 31 people dead the senate voted to
proceed to the bill just more than an
hour after negotiators unveiled its text
giving lawmakers little time to digest
its details
so
the bill is actually quite absurd i'm i
was reading that it doesn't mention guns
until like page 25.
it's mostly like a whole bunch of weird
medicaid
bloat that they couldn't get through
anywhere else and they were like uh gun
control and they just jammed a bunch of
trash into it but uh yeah the bill is
actually really bad
you've got the republican senator from
west virginia shelley moore capito who's
voting in favor of it which is nuts but
surprise surprise the gop is selling you
out
there's crisis intervention not red flag
laws
crisis intervention which is literally
the same thing
they want a 10-day waiting period and
juvenile check for all background checks
for anyone under 21 which basically
means from 18 to 21 as a legal adult you
will have basic what like a 10-day
waiting period which is what they've
been trying to do for a long time
i'm not gonna sit here and say that
they're trying to ban guns out right but
this is the game they play
they introduce a crazy bill and say we
want to ban weapons we want to raise the
the age to 21. everyone loses their mind
and they go okay okay fine
just enhanced background checks for
people over 18 but under 21. that's
acceptable right and magnitude is like
no what's acceptable would be the
republicans
change
what they did i think it was
pennsylvania they took the bill and they
just erased all the texts and put in
constitutional carry instead how about
that how about the republicans actually
stand up for our right to keep and bear
arms but um
makes me wonder like if uh a
shooter appears that has an illegally
acquired gun and does a mass shooting
like are they going to then
try and make it harder for people to get
weapons again like this is complete
insanity yeah exactly i mean look there
are so many laws on the books that would
have prevented virtually all of the mass
shootings that have become big news
stories but that hasn't prevented them
from trying to solve the problem by
introducing more laws to go back to your
point tim i disagree i mean i do think
they're trying to ban all guns i think
they know
that change occurs incrementally and
every time you point out okay yeah yeah
and so every time you point out that you
know that they go that's the slippery
slope fallacy which is not of course as
we have seen not a fallacy the slippery
slope fallacy is a fallacy if you're
saying you should only be against this
uh because it could lead to other things
but if you're able to explain why it
will based on a pattern we've seen in
the past of
incremental change constantly occurring
where the left says it won't then that's
not fallacious that's just pattern
recognition yep
yeah all right so we all agree then i
think that's a wrap for tonight good
show time for the after show let's get
dirty
you're right sheamus about i mean hitler
did it slowly it took him 10 years oh
about 19 i think they got started in not
29 33 really when hitler got the uh what
they call it the uh what was that act
that he signed that basically stripped
everybody's rights away the enabling act
yeah yeah they burned the reichstag
somebody burned it he blamed the
communists
and then research has been done on this
and they said you know there's no way
someone could these two guys that hitler
blamed or this one guy could have burned
that building the way it burned they
tried to replicate it they're like no no
this was like a they think it was a
staged planned event probably by hitler
to scare everyone in the country and
then do the the enabling and seize their
weapons so i'm quite pissed off at these
republicans yeah and one of the
republicans that supported this was uh
shelley moore capito of west virginia
and i'm kind of pissed because we're
currently building our new west virginia
headquarters and i was like this is a
state it's a great state to invest in to
bring our our business which is you know
going to bring in a lot of jobs and
we're expanding all thanks to all of you
as members at timecast.com
and now i have to deal with the
republican senator selling me out yo i'm
trying to move my business here they
really don't want it i'll tell you this
maryland hates us
and i don't mean as in like me
personally i mean maryland hates
business
like they have laws that are just like
we will flog you for being a business
it's so insane to start even a charity
in maryland's ridiculous costs yeah like
get your act together you guys do you
not want me to start a business here
they don't new jersey was the same way
it's like i would like to start a
business and bring you know wealth and
they would be like we're going to beat
over that instead well so we leave new
jersey we we have uh you know a part of
our operation in maryland and now going
through just the logistics of operating
in maryland i'm just like
it would it is better for the business
to shut everything down and and spend
like a million bucks to just move
everything out of maryland because it is
so hostile to business but now i got to
contend with this shelly moore capital
woman so i was just like okay i need to
confer with my lawyer as to how much
money i'm allowed to spend to make sure
she never wins re-election again and i'm
really pissed off about this perhaps the
only thing these people respond to are
leftist tactics like organizing 24 7
protests outside their homes or putting
up billboards all over their hometown
insulting them and and dragging their
character i'm sick of these people
they're scumbags and the problem is
conservatives there's too many too many
conservatives or cowards don't do
anything and that's why they do it these
gop members know that they can support
the democrats and republicans will
grumble and forget about it so i'm not
i'm not a republican i'm not a
conservative i'm more libertarian than
anything and i'm right pissed off that
this woman in the second most trump
supporting state just sold me out how
dare you madam i don't think i am gonna
put whatever i can to whatever legal
extent to make sure you are retired by
your re-election and you the problem is
she knows it her re-election is until
2026. she's old she's probably like well
i'll burn down the house because i'm
leaving anyway these people are absolute
scumbags corning as well
well we're going to negotiate on it's
not really red flag laws literally red
flag laws she puts out a statement she's
like we will never have red flag laws in
these states so you're just enacting a
federal legislation to expand red flag
laws but hoping it doesn't come to west
virginia you absolute scumbag well and
also this idea of negotiating right i
mentioned this on the show the other day
they'll talk about compromise it's not
compromise if you don't get anything out
of it it's not a negotiation if there's
no need for you to be having a
conversation with the person we've seen
the polling data we can't predict the
future but it's probably likely that
republicans are going to do pretty well
in the midterms so you'd think they'd be
able to look down the line and say we
have a little bit of leverage to not
have to cave into the left every single
time they demand something of us but you
know they're going to win the midterms
and everyone's going to clap and cheer
and then they're going to be like and
now what were you trying to pass
democrats exactly exactly now that we've
won and don't need to argue with you why
don't you move to florida coming to
florida yeah you know
west virginia's not all bad just because
this the center did one bad thing rhonda
santa's is pretty great but uh
uh the weather
it's more expensive
so west virginia is still a great place
uh for for expanding a business
land is cheap
much less regulation
uh you guys don't have constitutional
carry yet but i believe it's coming the
gun laws are still not that bad but you
know i lived in florida man and you
can't go out well i lived in miami for
for a year and you just can't go outside
yeah with a beanie yeah there are little
aspects on the side no ian you can't go
outside at all
hey man i'm with you i was in no way it
was in february it was like 99 degrees
in february you can go outside january
and february the windows on every
building are drenched yeah our ac
overloaded and started getting all this
condensation because i had cracked a
window and the entire it like flooded
the the ceiling it was they have a
statue of the man who invented air
conditioning in miami i'm not kidding
they warned us not to open so uh i'll
say this
you know i'm trying to think of like
what i can do
and i was thinking like maybe we can
start start a porta potty company and
call them shelley crappitos oh yeah or
maybe like shelly shelly capito boxes
and um i wonder if there's like a legal
issue of me doing that i i tweeted like
can i open a restaurant in charleston
west virginia which is the biggest city
it's only 50 000 people and then name
the restaurants shelly moore capitao is
trash
i'm i'm wondering i'm going to look into
how much it'll cost to buy every
billboard in that town
and put just putting up i'm not even
talking political ads just character ads
like you're you're a bad person you're
scum
you know
and just leaving and just buying them
indefinitely and i'm like it's good
marketing because people are going to be
like why are these ads here oh yeah tim
pool's really pissed off about this
make sure everybody knows how pissed off
i am
look
i i am i i said that i'll put a sticky
note on my monitor and i will say every
i'll put it this way
you know we have sponsors who who pay
good money for us to read out their ads
and all that i wonder what the with the
total monetary value of me ragging on
her would be if every single night i
said never forget she's a scumbag i
think when you said earlier about
organizing and getting people to to
rally obviously you don't want people to
go to people's houses and that's that's
not the but you can organize people to
call at 2pm on a day you make a video in
the morning and you tell people at 3 p.m
you call this number this office and
tell her that you want
whatever that you want her to reverse
her position on this and when she gets
780 calls a day for five days in a row
she will change her position yeah why do
you why do you have to do that why why
is her position this position like where
did the pressure come from
you know what i think it is she's not up
for re-election until 2026 she's
probably going to retire i don't know
she's going to be 60s or something or i
think she's in her 60s i think she's
going to be in her 70s maybe and so
she's probably like
what do i care i can burn the place down
on my way out and get what i want and
some people have pointed out that there
was some like i don't want to get too
much into it but some exchanges were
made let's just put it that way some say
there was some monetary movement in some
capacity that i'm not super familiar
with i'm not going to get into but she
probably cut a deal in my opinion they
came to her and said
look
you're not up for re-election until 2026
your voters are dumb as box of rocks so
they're going to completely forget that
that's how they think that's that's what
they think of you
by the time you're up for re-election
this will be a non-issue
so give it to us now we'll give you
these things and who cares anyway and
then they probably all pop the champagne
started laughing and spitting on
pictures of their constituents
i despise these people yeah it's not
obvious
but good
i know i think there is something to
what you're saying about putting these
people on blast regularly it's important
for your audience to hear especially
members of your audience who live in the
area who actually is interested in
representing their interests and who
will bend at the last moment it's very
disappointing that there were any
republicans who are willing to sign on
to this unfortunately some of them were
and i think we do have a duty to
criticize them it's it's also about
making contact you can criticize them in
the background but they're going to
ignore it unless you actually call the
office because it's that time the time
is more valuable than the money didn't
uh didn't chuck schumer say it was okay
to protest at the home of senators he
did that's insane yeah he did say that i
believe so so so it's okay chuck schumer
chuck schumer was wrong if he said that
why why is it wrong well he said it i
mean i think as far as i know it's
illegal no it's not it's illegal to
protest protest in front of the home of
a judge or a member of a report but
that's not getting enforced either right
so maybe the only thing these people
will answer to is an actual anger group
of protesters being like
you know what i'll put it this way
the left they do these things it works
for him republicans keep dropping to
their knees maybe it's about time some
younger
libertarian moderate conservative
whatever you want to call it started
saying okay we can play the game as well
yeah the united states is an angry group
of protesters that was what we were when
we started we still are the united
states is a protest a wise man told me
that one time it sounds a lot like mob
rule though you know you just get the
the mob with the pitchforks yeah running
the show and whoever has the the bigger
mob and there's the conundrum that's why
we have representatives
the the cultural right which has
expanded quite dramatically thanks to
the left um now incorporates post
liberals along with moderates and
conservatives as they continually just
say no no we don't do that here and the
left is like you got it buddy we do
then republicans keep just saying it's a
simple equation i'll give it to you in
terms of why twitter likes censorship
twitter like censorship for one reason
they have a lot of employees who are
very much into censorship but there's
also the fact that
do you think dave rubin is going to lead
a group of classical liberals with
pitchforks and bricks and molotov
cocktails on twitter hq and they're all
going to violence i agree we disagree
with you we disagree
you think do you think dave rubin would
ever lead a violent mob to that quarters
of twitter
i don't know about that probably not his
style yeah he definitely wouldn't know
his do you think antifa would
absolutely of course they their whole
thing and so when you have a dude
literally trying to kill a sitting
supreme court justice and people
illegally protesting at the at the homes
of justices the politicians know exactly
who they're afraid of they're terrified
of the left and the right wing is a
bunch of spineless cowards that they can
ignore because the right's always just
like well you know hold on there a
minute i remember back in like 2016 i
was out in front of trump tower in new
york and there was a bunch of people
protesting and there was one dude
leaning leaning up against the wall
we were talking he asked us some
questions because we were like
journalists covering the event and i was
like you know what what do you think you
support trump he's like oh yeah
definitely and then i was like so why
don't you start saying you support trump
no no no i don't want anyone to know i
was like okay dude secret trump voters
congratulations yeah but don't you see
like with the school board uh meetings
the pushback from parents the pushback
on disney a lot of this stuff like don't
you see the right getting a little fired
up and the parents in loudoun county are
waiting around a little bit more the
parent the parents and loud and a lot of
these parents that are speaking up
aren't conservatives they're just
regular people who are not doing it for
political reasons yeah we were talking
last night about how the right is really
everybody that's not being crushed into
this cult by the mass media yeah
and the way you framed it like the
teachers right the people the student
i'm sorry the parents rising up
the immediate assumption is that must be
the right that's how the media frames it
when you go and talk to these people
like i don't i don't know anything about
that loudoun county is like a suburb of
dc you know it's like a minute away from
here this is like a mixed very liberal
area these people are getting angry so
you take a look at uh you know i can put
it this way
twitter facebook youtube purged all of
the conservatives who are talking about
standing up and protesting
laura loomer chaining herself to twitter
hq oh they they ban her alex jones they
say those metaphors don't fly then you
get protesters outright breaking the law
and genseki encouraging him to do it and
you know social media companies like
yeah it's fine so what they don't have
to worry about they don't have to worry
about conservatives they have to worry
about parents
it's parents because parents it's not
political it's about their kids they
turned parents into a voting block
exactly which is crazy unbelievable yeah
they don't understand it's so funny
they'll um
you know they'll talk about like how
terrified they feel and how scared they
are of the right it's like all right if
you're scared of someone you don't start
screwing with their kids
yeah it's so obviously phony what can we
do you know i was so i've been doing uh
we we got a billboard in times square
which was like it was meant to be like a
big statement like we've arrived like we
are now in the space and that now a
whole bunch of other organizations like
you know the daily wire had the
timescale billboard for us we worked
together on one parlor bought the same
digital space that we did
and uh i'm also looking at like what's
the best way we've never spent any money
on marketing
and so one of the things we came up with
was direct marketing is a bad idea
what's a good idea is culture jamming as
marketing
so what we did in times square was
partly that some of the best marketing
was just calling out taylor lorenz for
being a liar that worked really well for
us and and the daily wire
and so i'm wondering like
can i just how much would it cost to buy
every billboard in town of 50 000. i'd
imagine it'd be like 20 grand you know
for a month because it's a small very
small city so okay what if we just
we just do that we just start
crowdfunding we start just taking major
cultural actions to make bold statements
and just
dominate the conversation set the news
cycle
yeah let's do it and it also enhances
local economies that's a good idea do
people pay a lot of attention to
billboards when every billboard in your
town is the same one ragging on your
your local politician i think people
will notice tim is going to put a
billboard outside of a supreme court
justice's house he's going to put a
billboard in a tim cass billboard on a
billboard you don't have to be hot
so during the lockdowns
i went to a sushi restaurant
and
they
nobody was wearing masks
we walk in the front door and we're
standing next to the like the host
podium or whatever and they're like put
a mask on and then i was like i was like
nobody's wearing masks and they're like
but you have to wear a mask and i was
like now hold on there a minute like
nobody in the restaurant is wearing a
mask and they're like they're eating and
i was like
we're planning on eating too and they're
like no you have to wear a mask now and
then i was like if i sit down in that
table five feet from me can i not wear
the mask and they're like yes but put
the mask on now and then i was like are
you serious and then all of the
employees go yes and i'm like dude i am
done with this
and i was like you know what i could do
i could hire someone to fly a sign in
front of their restaurant
or like offer coupons to a rival sushi
restaurant across the street or
something
why not why not actually do culture
jamming to make a statement against
those who don't believe in freedom who
are too cowardly or these politicians
how about i hire
50 people to fly signs all throughout
charleston west virginia that just are
dancing with signs saying that shelley
uh capito is trash just that make sure
everybody knows there's disdain for this
person there's value to dogging on your
opponent there's also value to enhancing
the people you believe in so i think
both are effective you know the funny
thing is
someone tweeted at me that
as an individual you can spend as much
money as you want in any kind of
political statement and that there are
some limits but if you're doing as
educational in fact it could be even tax
deductible or something and i'm like i
don't know about all that like i'll just
talk to my lawyer and be like what am i
allowed to do in terms of ragging on
rhinos because uh i think it would be
excellent marketing for tim cast and the
podcast to make like an ad that's like
come watch our podcast and this
politician is a piece of garbage
i think it'd be great advertising you
know but that is political so certain
billboards won't run it because it's
political
maybe if i just say the person's name is
garbage then it's a free speech thing
like we were we were able to say taylor
lorenz is a liar
or no no
i think we said taylor lauren's doc's
libs of tick tock that's what it was and
the the the the
time square billboards like that's fine
yeah
as long as we weren't advertising a
product
we're just making a statement part of it
is i think
a good thing for you personally to do is
to stay cool stay calm and organized
it's a vague like like where's the
where's the call to action in it and it
might not be for you that might be for
i'm speaking to myself because you're
very good with fire
and uh you know aggression and stuff
like that
um but i think it's the long game it's
gonna be a 50-year 100 year they need
you calm and
able to see the big picture i'm just
taught you know what i'm really bored
with
it's like
everything's just so routine and yeah
and the same thing exactly the left
comes out there's a double standard
imagine if we did this yeah and then
exactly the same thing over and over
again and i'm like won't someone please
throw a figurative pie the name the name
calling falls into that though with the
it's it's boring it's repetitive you
know everyone's a racist everyone's a
bigot everyone who disagrees with you is
disinformation you know yeah
hate speech hate speech but that's you
know it's just so repetitive it's
monotonous it's but a fun house it loses
its effectiveness when it's just
it's applied to everybody that you
disagree with it's true let's put a
funhouse mirror in front of these
people's faces yeah i saw um
a while ago and this is something we all
see frequently but someone posted an
article on twitter about the racist
origins of blank and they said look this
is really interesting articles like how
could any article calling something
racist be interesting at this point
right how could you possibly read them
like wow what an original thought you
called something you didn't like racist
seth does that still get clicks yeah
that's a good question just give me a
random noun
uh a person placer thing a random noun
random i guess make it a good oh that
one's too obvious
get a little bit more obscure dog
that was my first
okay i'm gonna put this way i gotta go
i'm going to search for a noun as racist
dog is
racist yeah
yeah why is my dog racist can dogs be
racist can dogs be racist what to do if
your dog seems racist and dogs be racist
i think their dog is racist my dog is
racist look up dogs are racist i'm sure
you'll see some article about
gentrification i i
yeah i remember the article
what it's it's the same thing ask amy i
think their dog is racist i looked up
amygdala the effects of skin tone on
race-related amygdala activity
i mean maybe maybe it's like that's
that's houses are genetically realistic
well this one's easy
well of course they are yeah
yep i mean that one's obvious but
give me a good noun
oh come on that one's too obvious no no
it's not that obvious computers are
racist
kids when computers are racist rise of
the racist robots master enslave the
fight over offensive terms can computers
be racist come on these are green news
guards certified artificial intelligence
is racist even ai is racist computer
programmers about mugs and sex
mugs
yeah eyeglasses mugs are racist
racist oh now it's selling me stuff
there you go capitalism amazon racist
coffee so the thing is we did learn that
there are indeed racist mugs turns out
you can buy it racist
no like this one's all selling starbucks
oh i know that's what i race them with a
message racism 101 mugs cocktails and
statues bro i'm telling you you can get
this one's funny because the entire
search is like they're trying to sell
you racist money but there was one
market for it there's one article
talking about mugs [ __ ] dozen statues
racism 101. okay i got a good now for
you racism racism
let's find out
probably not won't be able to find it i
mean i was told love
racism might be racist i mean is that
really a thing though racism i don't
know i mean the problem there is that i
don't think google search can accurately
understand what that gotcha can't deal
with tautologies yeah uh flags are
racist what about
uh confederate battle flag how americans
feel about the u.s flag why is the
confederate flag racist oh of course
that's the most time of the confederate
let's do this let's do minus confederate
minus confederate
why they weren't he's using google
yeah
american flag flyers are racist yeah
remember the flags on trucks journalists
are freaking out he's just it's all
racist
mowing your lawn is racist i saw an
article about that
your lawn is doing any landscaping at
all it's privileged it's super racist
better to have tall grass
manicured longs are racist
i'm trying to find out if ninjas are
racist
i'm sure
though he could be joking he's
definitely yeah but i'm not sure if he's
actually referencing anything in that
joke as well i think i think ryan long
did this bit where he was like
you know how to write an article and
then he was like just what was it he was
like pulling nouns and adjectives out of
a hat yeah why blank is blank and then
he showed all the articles that actually
existed
that was just absolutely insane
the dogs being racist one is actually
was a big deal
because a bunch of people were pointing
out that they were saying
dogs are a sign of gentrification
and dogs themselves are racist because
they like bark at you know minorities or
something like that well and so in a
weird way this is obviously a sign of
cultural decay but there's also
something here about the bubble that's
existed within the new media landscape
so you've talked about this before but
basically you had a lot of venture
capitalists investing in blog type
websites and news sites so these
companies were way overvalued they hired
a bunch of people to write articles
there's only so many things you can
write articles about so eventually you
just got a bunch of stuff about racism
and the market became oversaturated with
stuff that no one was really reading let
me talk to you guys about this we we
briefly mentioned it a couple days ago
the dead internet theory do you guys
know about interesting theory yeah from
the other day i remember this the dead
internet theory is that
in 2016 and 17
that's when
major corporations government figures
took over most social um elements of the
internet and replaced humans with bots
or that the bots dramatically outweigh
the production of content than humans do
so the internet is actually a zombie
you think you're interacting with other
people just like you but you're really
just interacting with bots and it's it's
a decent theory i mean the idea is
simple
donald trump was memed into the
presidency
regular people went online and said
here's what we want trump wins and they
went uh-oh that's bad
then you get a bunch of companies that
start running stock puppet accounts and
bot accounts trying to make money or
manipulate and not it's not a conspiracy
even though they call it a conspiracy
theory it's like the natural tendency of
what corporations would do to try and
gain influence and sell products but i
got one more for you this one's for you
guys uh sheamus and seth
i think this is um
bot person theory
the actual the actual conspiracy theory
in my opinion
is that 2016 2017 is the point at which
the internet
crossed the threshold of being the most
dominant media
network for human beings
newspapers television telephone were now
underneath the internet
and with all people being online we're
now realizing that most people are as
dumb as a box of rocks effectively
non-player characters so
to uh to to somebody who's used to
having a real conversation
to being um
you know uh politically discerning or
introspective they're seeing a whole
bunch of people post the same thing
repeat themselves
regurgitate
and this is this other theory started
the person basically said i've seen the
same post over and over again i've seen
the same comments repeated at nauseum
and i'm just like
you want to believe the robots but it
could just be that most people are just
sheep and are just vomiting up the same
thing they heard
and the reality is it's people
that's the creepy thing i i think it's a
better explanation it's if if i'm there
and i'm real and you're there and you're
real and you're there and you're we're
all there we're real there's a lot of
real people there it's not all bots
there's obviously a lot of people
involved in this thing it's not all dead
and people do just parrot these lines
over and over and it's mindless you know
they just they just say whatever they're
supposed to say
and or what they've heard they
regurgitate what they've heard
i see it all the time and it seems like
bot behavior but it's really just people
we are we have become bots we're
basically just machines just
regurgitating stuff
yeah and uh you got to be you got to be
careful not to fall into that trap
yourself when you're engaging with them
well then you just start saying what
you're supposed to say in response to
that and you're engaging in your own you
know like
that's why i post nonsense on twitter
that's why i said you know figuratively
throw a pie like do something weird yeah
i posted an ai trump as a chicken yeah i
was you know i've always i thought this
my whole life
i was just like how come no one ever
does anything unpredictable like it's
not really true that's never but 80 of
the time it's completely predictable 20
of the time you're going to be surprised
by what someone does and i was just like
for the most part everybody's walking
around doing exactly what you'd expect
them to do not a single person decides
to do anything weird that's why some
people do sorry they're all just
thinking really weird things yeah that's
when i started making internet videos
like what would jesus christ do with
this modern technology he'd make
internet videos and try and spread the
got so i was like i'll do it
and so i did it and that was weird and
it's not me that's not weird i'm
completely routine and boring of course
everyone's doing it right um it's it's
the natural order what i'm saying is
like how come no one's buying
porta-potties and labeling them shelly
more capital
you know you know what i mean like
you've got all these powerful wealthy
people who are complaining but doing
nothing or doing very little
i think the power of making an internet
video is is misunderstood it's it's not
quite the power you have the resonation
of your vibration through voice and
light is so powerful dude if i'm if i
made 50 million bucks a year or
something like that i would just go to
these companies and be like how many how
much will it cost to buy like 10 times
square billboards and just put up the
same thing
just doing something weird like ragging
on shelly more capital well so i i will
answer with the jordan peterson quote
right
it's like it's not many people are
creative and it's not obvious why you
would want to be because like creative
people are miserable when they're not
doing creative things and he sort of had
this very insightful interesting
explanation there but yeah it's
basically that i mean most people are
not creative in the way that we usually
define the term
and so
they're not interested in doing those
kinds of things i think when somebody is
more creative and they do have means
they're often afraid to do anything
interesting with it man that's lame just
because uh sure but i think it's the way
things are because they're afraid
is buying twitter elon is a very unique
example right and we sort of we talked
about this with jeremy boring right
we're just sort of comparing elon to
bezos and he described bezos is one like
the most good the most boring
interesting person or most interesting
boring person it's like he builds a
rocket but it's not cool right exactly
exactly uh so i think you see a lot of
that um is it do you think that people
with means that are creative they're
afraid of being told that they suck well
no so i think that's part of it i think
that everyone has an excuse not to do
the interesting thing they want to do
so when you don't have a lot of money
it's i could never do this because i
couldn't afford to then when you do have
money well i could never do this because
i could never afford to damage my
reputation or risk my wealth i guess
people are scared of their reputations
or something yeah i just that's the
biggest brand yeah
people yeah yeah people always have been
i think we put more emphasis on it today
and i think we've been trained to we've
become very narcissistic but it's it's
huge for me isn't there a point where
you just have so much money they say
it's fu money but it's not it's not i
i mean let's be real can we name
i guess elon musk is buying twitter
which is cool it's not particularly
outrageous
it did anger many people on the left but
it's actually a relatively
i
it's it's it's a big it's a big bold
move but it's not throwing a pie you
know what i mean you don't think so no
no no throwing a pie would be like
buying a super bowl commercial or buying
a billboard of ian and hollywood just
saying i remember you and just like
culture jamming well i just from my
perspective i never expected you know i
was i was trying to think to myself what
would be a possible solution to this
issue of viewpoint discrimination
happening on these platforms you know
like
that there's either going to be some
kind of a law that's passed possibly you
know congress could get involved and
draft legislation or the courts could do
something i never in a million years
thought oh well maybe the richest man in
the world is going to come along
describe himself as a free speech
absolutist and buy the platform and fix
the problem you know it was it was a it
was a a curveball it was unexpected so
if you go back to the point that you
were making about no one ever does
anything unexpected like who expects
that someone's going to come in and
offer more than the company's worth just
to make a point about how this needs to
be for speech i would say it's uh it's
on the line you know a rich guy buying
something expensive is like okay
it is it is surprising that someone made
a move like that but it's not like if
elon came out and said he was gonna put
a hundred million dollars into making a
rival news organization that would be
like whoa and if and but i will say elon
definitely fits the bill definitely um
because he tweets things that like aoc
like stopped making me blush like yeah
absolutely amazing yeah but so he's
definitely doing it he trolls people
very effectively very nice i think it's
also a definitional problem right
because if you're asking why aren't
people usually doing things that are
unpredictable if they were it would be
predictable i mean by definition for
something to be unpredictable it has to
happen infrequently but you like
i'm just saying
there are a lot of very wealthy people
that are and many of them are are
somewhat uh directly or potentially
involved in like culture war issues
and like how come nobody just does bold
weird things save elon right because you
know he tweet tweeting him tweeting at
aoc was hilarious buying twitter is
massive it's like
i'm just i i've talked about this many
times there's very few people who just
do the weird thing what donald trump did
with the uh the apprentice that was so
weird and then he did the president
thing yeah but then he ran for president
and he always kind of yeah that's weird
that one was weird
we could acknowledge we could
acknowledge like we've said this a
number of times if you told someone 10
years ago that trump was going to be
president and the deep state was going
to try to see him and everything that's
happened we would go i don't believe
that just just some weird things
seriously just let's pause for a second
imagine it's 2012 and you're like
sitting with your buddy and like you're
in the living room and you're and you're
he's like you're like i've come back
from the future 10 years and he's like
wow what happened you're like okay well
uh donald trump ran for president
against hillary clinton and won and then
a bunch of special interests accused him
of secretly working with russia and even
msnbc had a guest on entertaining that
he may have been a soviet agent going
back to the 80s he ultimately won then
joe biden gets elected donald trump
supporters think the election was stolen
so a large several hundred stormed the
capitol building during the electoral
directoral vote counting process texas
files a lawsuit against pennsylvania and
half the country and other half the
country are now involved in whether or
not the election was legitimate they're
going to be like
what
that's
so was obama's birth certificate real or
fake yeah
did we get to the bottom of it yeah did
we ever get to the point we ever figured
that out um how does lost and no i guess
that was probably out so
let me try and phrase uh what i mean
it's like because obviously elon musk is
doing funny things but like he's not
doing funny things like buying a hundred
porta-potties and putting the name of a
senator on it and distributing them
around fairgrounds i think you should
just do it you're fixated on that
you really want to do what you want to
see in the world
it's a really good example no no it's
eight hundred dollars per porta potty
yeah so you know so we
spend 80 thousand dollars on 100 porta
bodies and then just be like they're
free
you know like oh what's that you're
doing called construction companies and
be like we'll just give it to you just
use it and they're called shelly boxes
i think another thing that happens and
this is really insidious and it's not
accounted for often but
there's an entire set of behaviors that
we are told are weird and quirky and
interesting but which are really boring
and predictable so a lot of folks feel
like they're doing something unique or
new when they're just sort of going
along with the program so
there are a lot of examples of this we
see this with the activism a lot of
these companies engage in where they'll
they'll make their corporate logo a gay
pride flag or something and it's okay
well that's the most predictable thing
you can do but you think it's edgy and
brave and interesting
or at least for a time they did at this
point they're probably willing to
acknowledge that this is just the thing
you're expected to do and don't do and
don't forget july is maga month so
everyone's got to change their logos to
american flags
and i'm doing it
i'm going to i'm going to get graphics
made you know my twitter profile will be
my face with the american flag behind it
i like that but i mean how often i'm
sure we've all encountered this where
somebody gives you the most banal
predictable advertiser friendly
perspective as if it's something new and
original
all the time i mean it's constant it's
like whenever someone's like you know
what like i don't like christianity or
like well i
and it's like okay i it's like i
understand that but can you acknowledge
that that's a very safe position but
people don't do that anymore like their
view has to be unique and interesting
even when it's plainly banal
i wonder if it's just
you know if
from
in my perspective most people they play
music because they looked up to someone
and want to emulate somebody else most
people just want to emulate someone else
so they want to fit in they want to stay
in line i wonder how many people
genuinely don't care about fitting in
and i wonder if that's technically like
a mental illness
i mean it because humans are our social
beings you want to fit in to survive so
it takes a very rare individual to be
like literally don't care if i fit in or
not like what would what would i do
if you know we were like nomadic
tribesmen you know thousands of years
ago and i was being arrogant like i
don't want to do what you say screw you
they bet get out and i'd be like well
i'm going to go die i guess in the
middle of the woods so it's like i talk
about making these shelly boxes
but would people really be like you're
would they be like that's great or
they'd be like you're really disrupting
what we're trying to do here i made
outhouse put poster on it they'd be like
yeah leave now yeah rug they're like
this is one toilet leading our tribe
leave now
or or is the reality that the the
outliers and the weirdos end up being
the leaders sometimes sometimes they're
snuffed out you never hear about them i
think what ends up happening is a
sociopath uh
like the the narcissists and the
egotists end up becoming the leaders
people who are like i should be in
charge and then once they're in charge
like i can lie cheat and steal and
whatever because i'm better than you i
think ben franklin was a nut job but he
was so organized that he was able to
create uh a periodical you know the poor
richard's almanac and distribute
propaganda for 30 years to brainwash
people into thinking that freedom was
the way and that they should revolt
against the king so he worked out do
what ben franklin did fly a kite in a
storm with a key on it yeah
absorb electricity it's time to do that
too get weird
i'm starting to buy into here he was
crazy theory
yeah that's a good point ben franklin
he's a polymath they call them talking
about weird stuff though let's talk
about what you guys do the babylon bee
oh thanks because
good transition good transition no but i
mean like you're you are figuratively
throwing pies you're you're calling out
you're calling out hidden truth as it
were through jokes a good example is
when uh you guys had an article that
said
ingenious move donald trump comes out in
support of impeachment forcing democrats
to oppose
and that is a very clever way to comment
on the fact that they just oppose
whatever it is trump or you know trump
supporters are doing yeah yeah he said
it therefore it's bad orange man bad
orange man bad
well that's that goes back to how
everybody's like a bot you know that's
bot behavior to just have a predictable
response to whatever it you know there's
something that you're supposed to be
opposed to so you just you oppose it
i don't know i mean with the internet
though you know instagram and all these
things there's
people are
just trying to do what you're supposed
to do on these platforms everyone's that
has the same family pictures they all do
the same things but if you're trying to
throw pies and be disruptive then that's
your thing you're trying to do it it has
to be something that you're not
deliberately trying to do it just has to
be coming from you naturally it's
because that's how you are as a person
you're different otherwise you're both
doing something for a purpose you're
trying to get a certain kind of response
people are either trying to fit in or
they're trying to be different i mean
get a response by being different that's
true i i don't i don't take issue with
someone being like let's throw a pie
figuratively because you know don't
actually throw pies at people but uh
like when i'm on twitter i'll just
randomly i'll post some nonsense if i'm
feeling like it like i posted jeremiah
was a bullfrog the other day because i
just i just you know yeah i thought it
was fun you need to be more responsible
it was it was a whim
literally i was listening to three dog
night and so joy of the world came on
and i just typed it in hit enter and i
didn't think twice and i was like so you
made a point about people being bots and
we've sort of talked about this a little
bit there are obviously some issues
where it makes sense to to stand strong
have base principles so when you're
talking about something where you would
say there is an axiomatic evil or you're
talking about like abortion or some
matter of like human sexuality such as
homosexuality you're talking about theft
property etc it makes sense that you
would have set positions because of what
your principles are but then when it
comes to a question of whether a
specific person is guilty
in a court case or a national story
that's not something you can just jump
to one side or the other on that's
something you have to see evidence for
but we are at the point where any time
there is a news story about a police
officer shooting someone
a large
subsection of the country has decided
he's guilty and it was unjustified
without any evidence at all
conservatives are still
are still defending ahmed arbore
like yeah that one that one that one to
me is like
because we had lawyers on talking about
that i think my point is there are a lot
of stories that we see in the public eye
where it's just a question of a specific
person their behavior whether they're
guilty of the thing that they're accused
of and people are hyper-polarized on it
and i think this has happened because
we're just used to being hyper-polarized
but it's different right because again
when it comes to the other issues it's a
matter of principle whether a specific
person is guilty or innocent when i
don't have evidence is not something
that my principles can determine it's
something the evidence will determine
once we get it but people take sides
before they see or hear anything of
substance abuse and the entirety of the
left including establishment democrats
moderate liberals default liberals and
leftists
will blindly march in lockstep yep
they'll get angry about it they'll
protest about it and they'll scream in
your face and try and take your job and
conservatives are lukewarm and we'll be
like okay we'll agree with you on that
one yeah and the fun thing about satire
is it gives you a way to point all of
that out in a way that like makes the
point you know right it makes it into a
joke where you're you're seeing that and
you're exposing it for what it is the
absurdity of it did you see the uh
subverting it fast company wrote an
article saying something like beware the
far-right comedy or whatever or
right-wing comedy and they're like from
joe rogan to the babylon b to like the
daily wire
and i just think it's funny that uh
they they still try and push these memes
where they're like the right can't make
jokes or it's not funny but the weird
thing is
it used to be the perception that that
conservatives weren't funny and the left
was there was in the article they talk
about how fox tried doing some kind of
jon stewart show back in the day that
just didn't work and it failed but now
you've got gutfeld who who on fox news
he's he gets way way better ratings than
any of the primetime com comedians on on
major networks you take a look at the
onion bro i imagine that that used to
read the onion yeah of course what
happened to them
so the problem a lot of the reason why
these late night comedians and the onion
and whatever are falling off is because
they're not
what the comedian the satirist the
humorist is supposed to be doing is
poking holes in the popular narrative
not promoting it you know all they do is
push it all they do is push it and the
big tech companies are you know trying
to rig the systems that you're not
allowed to poke holes in the popular
narrative if you do that then you're
engaging in hate speech or you're
spreading misinformation or whatever but
this is what's killing comedy in my
opinion you know they say oh we're not
funny well we have more engagement in
traffic than the onion at this point
we're the we're the most popular satire
site in the world and they're and
they're sitting there saying we're not
funny well obviously we're engaging
people and the reason we're engaging
people is because we're actually making
fun of the powers that be and trying to
uh hold that power accountable and poke
holes in the popular narrative instead
of promote it which is what comedians
are supposed to do i i grew up with the
onion because i think they were based on
what milwaukee i think and i remember
when we would get the physical onion
paper uh when we were in chicago look at
this one excerpts from jenny thomas's
emails attempting to overturn the 2020
election cnn no it's too political is
that yeah right i could say they weren't
political in the early days well this is
the thing they were in a
preacher not drenched in sweat must not
be very connected to a holy spirit there
you go
what's what's the joke now fine you know
whenever i point this out there was one
story that was literally it was
literally not a joke
and then i was like
legit what is the joke here and they
were like you're so dumb you don't get
the joke and i'm like i guess so dude i
don't care like you can laugh at me
because i don't get it that's fine it
means i don't read your outlet right you
know
it would have been like preachers
connected to holy spirit why isn't he
sweating they they missed they missed i
don't think that one's there it's not
funny i'll put it this way i mean
the onion is not what it used to be they
used to be very political and this is
over the past couple of years not jokes
no yeah but over the past couple years
so probably about two or three years ago
i rediscovered the videos that they were
producing i want to say between 2008 and
2011 and they're so
funny their youtube channel was
incredible for just a couple years and
part of it was because they actually had
a tv show and those clips on youtube
were excerpts from them
yeah but they let's be real they used to
be very funny even when they got
political is my point they were still
funny and even when they had a message i
didn't agree with politically i thought
they were hysterical the grabblers video
that was great you know the grabblers no
i don't know that one it's an onion
video it's an onion video we cannot play
it here yeah we definitely can't play
even though it's on youtube really funny
where basically it's a mockery of a
morning news show and they bring on this
female author to help them visualize
their their stresses and she's like this
little old woman like everybody has
problems with money i want you to
imagine your money problem and then she
basically goes on to describe jewish
people
and then makes a bunch of really
offensive jokes but the point was
what was funny about it was that this
little old lady was basically trying to
sneak in like these anti-semitic tropes
and that was the joke that was the onion
that did that they also had that
autistic reporter bit
totally ableist you wouldn't be able to
get away with that these days they had
funny jokes now look i pulled up this
joke and it's okay let me here you go
here's here's their joke hey current
chief of staff mark meadows it's me
jenny thomas wife of clarence thomas
urging you to illegally overturn the
results of the 2020 election as i am
involved with a group of alt-right
radicals who if unhappy with the results
will storm the capitol building in
washington dc on january 6 2021 i agree
with their goals and methodologies
full-heartedly and again i jenny thomas
am unabashedly requesting that this
illegal action should be taken
where's the joke but like this is
something ridiculous i would write if
the joke was that like this is what
democrats think a republican is saying
like that would be the bit i pulled up
their 2001. i got into onion in 2001.
boyfriends ceremoniously dumped i mean
these were the articles and they were
and they would show a picture of a
person's face and they would reuse that
same so you would imagine this is the
writer it was like a fake person or or
just some random stock photo they got so
imagining who was saying it helps
the comedy i thought yeah in the early
days
you know what i think like
it's clapter right you guys know what
clapter is yeah yeah you're just you
just agree there's like a vague you know
set up punchline formula
clapping because it's when colbert comes
out and he's like donald trump's dumb
and they'll go
and start clapping it's like he didn't
say anything it's not amusement you're
going for it's applause you're going for
yeah so i look at a lot of that and
there's a lot of just avoiding hurting
people's feelings by being offensive now
you know the woke the woke mind virus as
elon musk calls it has infected all of
these comedians on the left you know and
so they're all the jokes that they would
have made years ago that are funny
they're capable of making those jokes
but they're not willing to make them now
because they cross a line an imaginary
line that they made up there was a
really good one they did a couple of
years ago um the onion is like 10 years
ago it patriotic teen fail spanish
and it was just a video where they're
like interviewing this kid as a brave
patriot for failing spanish and
obviously the point of that joke was to
poke fun at the right but i still i
thought it was hilarious when i saw it
and it's a funny video
now it's not it's not just that they
have a left-wing bias it's that today
having a left-wing bias means you have
to explicitly oppose anything that's
even remotely funny
here's one farmer caught googling what
is corn it's like okay well yeah
it's a different company with the same
name i don't know
man companies sell another owner and
then they keep the same name that's
scandalous also i'd be curious to know
because there are clearly some duds here
we're obviously remembering the ones
that were really funny that's why they
stick out to us yeah yeah so i'm
wondering also if there's just a
selection bias here because none of
these are going to stand the test of
time and maybe probably some boring yeah
but there were a couple funny ones we
saw when we were younger that we really
remember i think that stuff that used to
be funny is no longer funny too because
we get used to it and like you gotta you
gotta one-up it you know you gotta take
it to the next level or or go home there
was one they did too it was like uh new
humane um tim what we were just watching
like new humane death penalty uh
contraption oh he ripped the person's
head off it showed they actually did a
cgi machine that clamps the person down
and then a giant robotic claw grabs
their head and spins it and rips it off
their body and then it raises it up and
a hammer just starts bashing it for no
reason that was funny it was funny it
was that was like 10 years ago even
stuff like now there's obviously even
with that you could argue there's vague
political undertales you know they're
making a statement about the death
penalty and how about barbaric they
believe it is but it's funny it's funny
you can make a political point still be
funny but they don't it was funny
because after it already killed the
person a hammer starts bashing
well
i'll tell you some of the some of the
criticism that we've gotten like slate
did a piece about us um and a couple
other publications have written pieces
like this where they say here's the
reason the babylon b's not funny they're
not funny because
they're
rather than having their jokes tethered
to the truth or reality their jokes are
riding on the back of some political
narrative and so what they're saying is
there's fake news that we're attaching
our jokes to so we're promoting fake
news with satire that's like riding on
the top of that does that make sense
whereas the onion or left wing comics
are rooted in reality
and and i feel like it's exactly the
opposite like and the validation of that
is the fact that our jokes constantly
come true you know we make these jokes
and they come true it's like well
there's a reason they come true it's
because we were we were on we were on to
something there was a point to the joke
that we were making and reality just
caught up to us yeah sometimes within a
matter of hours the onions jokes don't
come true as often as our jokes their
jokes aren't as attached to reality as
ours are honestly the onion had two
really really good jokes in the past few
years one was presidency already aging
joe biden 10 years and it showed a
rotted corpse yeah like that was good
and then the other one was uh this was
back in like 2019 or 2020 and it said
naked andrew yang appears from time
portal to warn us about you know ai in
the future or whatever like that was
also pretty good there was so and this
is something i've experienced before too
with just like cracking a joke about
something and it turns out to be true a
few years down the line because these
people are generally pretty predictable
but there was a really great babylon bee
article i want to highlight public
school student can't read but is already
racist at a 12th grade level i thought
like that's hilarious that's a good joke
and i just i don't understand how
someone can read that and be like that's
clearly fake news disguised as a
punchline it's like no that is very
obviously a joke and so a while ago as
i'm sure you know and i've brought it up
on the show a number of times
snopes did an extremely
pseudo-scientific analysis of babylon b
articles where they literally they
rewrote the headlines to remove the joke
right make it sound like it was an
actual story and then asked people do
you think that this is an actual story
and then based on the number of people
who said yes
they totaled them as people who thought
the original babylon b headline was a
true story so they said of course we
have to fact check satire nobody
highlighted that study they didn't
conduct this oh they didn't conduct that
it was done at some university and then
they republished it
so the findings but they they didn't
just rewrite our headlines they
literally
reworded them so they didn't sound like
jokes no they they took the jokes out
yeah they took the joke out stripped it
of its like comedic you know structure
yes and removed the image and the image
is usually like a silly photoshop you
know like a
fake looking photoshop or a ridiculous
outlandish image they take that away too
and just present you with this like
you know headline that maybe it could be
true i don't know but it certainly
doesn't sound like a joke so
one example um oh sorry so so one
example was you guys did a bit that was
like uh it's it's with a picture of some
news anchor and it says
god allowed the mueller report to test
our unshakeable faith in collusion um
and they reworded it as cnn news anchor
anderson cooper said his belief that
trump colluded with russia is unshakable
uh
uh it will not change regardless of
statement or evidence to the contract
that is a completely different different
sentence yeah and so to ask people if
one sounds true and then when they
answer that it does sound true to apply
it to the first statement it's just
totally dishonest how do you i have
issues with satire and that i'm
concerned when people don't know it's
satire how do you like how do you manage
that
with people not knowing it yeah because
if some article comes up and you don't
know ahead of time like this is a satire
newspaper and which is a lot of times
why they ask you to put satire on the s
do they like with your descriptions in
like your twitter or like any other
i mean they can
it's labeled satire in the sense that if
you actually click on our website you
know like our tagline is fake news you
can trust and like you know our about us
page is obviously a joke but we don't
put on every article this is satire and
then close the article with what you
just read with satire you know we're not
just it kind of kills the joke to be
constantly reminding people this is a
joke so you can't do that really yeah so
you have to just present it and people
either get or they don't and a lot of
people don't well i want to point out
real quick you mentioned selection bias
for the onion so i pulled up the wayback
machine and i looked at a few
ten-year-old archival posts and like
yeah they're not particularly funny to
be honest um there's a few ones and i
think there's something interesting i
see here because some of these do make
me want to chuckle super bowl veterans
much more prepared for big games unique
stresses
rookies often rattled by pools of
boiling blood scything blades
psychosexual hallucinations like okay
that one's at least a little edgy and it
gave me a chuckle and you look at the
modern stuff now and it's kind of just
like hey you know like there's one
that's like kill your dad and it's like
a woman like waving something at her dad
i'm like it's just not doing comedy now
you're tiptoeing through a minefield
comedians are literally getting attacked
on stage chappelle's attacking that's
chris rock was slapped in the face you
know like other people there's you know
there's stories about that there was
just one in the new york post a few a
couple of weeks ago you know about how
it's not just you you've heard about a
lot of these cases but there's cases
happening at smaller comedy clubs too
where comedians are feeling like they
need armed security to go on stage and
make jokes because they're going to
offend somebody who's going to get
violent
or the right to keep and bear arms
right and defend themselves right yeah
you mentioned this
uh term that snopes uses which is
labeled satire which i just also want to
highlight there's something a little bit
sneaky there right like this isn't
obviously satire it's labeled satire but
it's still like it leaves the question
of whether you guys intend it to be
satire or not that's intentional yeah
that's intentional like a news
organization that's masked as a satire
organization well because their position
is and they haven't changed their
position is that we are claiming to be a
satire site so that we can mislead
people yeah how does that even make
sense
it's a claim new york times described us
as a far-right misinformation site that
sometimes traffic some misinformation
under the guise of satire wow so like a
comedian that'd be like
that's a long way of saying it's a
comedian right
under the guise of satire though you
know we're putting it on we're wearing
the costume we're we're claiming we're
satire but it says satire on the website
it says fake news at the top of the
website well and also like like he said
that you know the the pictures that go
along with the articles yeah are clearly
photoshopped a lot of context clues yeah
that is usually like a setup punchline
formula in the headline like if people
are not discerning enough to understand
the difference between reality and
fantasy it's not
my fault i can't i can't well lower the
bar
idiots there's a big difference too by
the way human bot theory it's not the
internet it's the people yeah there's a
big difference between you know a fake
news site and this is what they're
trying to lump us in with you know
you'll see a fake news site that pops up
and they want to get clicks they do a
story about how kevin hart dies in car
accident and that's the headline kevin
hart dies tragically in car accident
well it didn't happen and that's not a
joke it's not funny they're just making
up a fake headline it's a lie and it's a
lie that gets clicks because people are
like oh my god did kevin hart die and
then they share it
so you know when we write a joke you
know that's not what we're we're not
just trying to like throw something out
there that might get clicks there's a
point there's a punch line you know
there's a and the whole thing ties
together the headline the image
everything it all ties together so
you're never gonna be able to get a
hundred percent of your audience to
understand that you're doing satirical
jokes you don't remember the the
legendary babylon b article kevin hart
died yeah it was it was huge it went
viral it was tragic kevin hart dies in
car accident that's our best headline
yeah
did you guys get banned off twitter did
babylon b get banned off twitter there
was some drama about it a couple months
ago or something babylon b
uh did a joke well so the usa today
named rachel levine woman of the year oh
right and uh and babylon b responded to
that we did a joke about how rachel
levine had been picked as our man of the
year
and uh and twitter didn't like that very
much so yeah we got uh we got reported
for hateful conduct and we were told to
delete the tweet wow um and basically
instead of them just taking it down
which you know to my thinking if they
have a problem with this tweet they can
take it down they don't have to force me
to like bend the knee and admit that i
did something wrong but they want us to
say that we engaged in hateful conduct
and acknowledge that and delete the
tweet and take it down and so what we've
done we've been in twitter jail for
three months because we've refused to oh
awesome but as soon as elon
makes that purchase
as soon as elon makes that purchase
we'll see i mean we're he's given us no
assurances but i would expect that that
if he does go through if the deal does
go through and elon musk takes over
twitter then i would expect it so
situations like ours would be corrected
well we'll see i pulled up the onion
from september 13th 2001. yeah that's
what i'm you're going way back now
that's when i was reading it this one
actually i kind of think it's funny a
guy's gone wild and it's a fat dude
pulling his shirt up with stars over his
nipples other than that it is it is not
particularly funny that sucker jesus has
forgiven me for some pretty bad sins
yeah that's pretty great like and then
this article right here it's just like
congressman admits to sexual
relationship that doesn't even sound
like satire right yeah that's just like
not at this point i don't even know if
it is to be honest they were literally
just saying gordon graham admits to an
affair it's like okay it's kind of like
i have you guys been parodying putin
much these days like stuff putin's up to
and putin like eating ice cream and all
that crap mostly biden not so much
yeah i got one here from the onion in
2001 starving bandage bin laden offers
u.s one last chance to surrender
and i mean that was to me it was like
crying and i was working at ground zero
at that period of my life like smelling
the the wreckage whatever was the bodies
or the
and it was still hilarious hilarious
because it wasn't hateful i mean there's
people they're not doing it to hurt
people right it's like you gotta you
gotta enjoy life even the chaos and
soldiers will tell you that too in the
middle of the heat of the battle you
still gotta you gotta find humor in like
some of the craziest stuff
i guess it's because it's lacking the
argument is that it's lacking context
when it's just like a post with no
i don't know what is it on twitter
there's like no picture
or but if so if that were the case then
why wouldn't they conduct an actual
reasonable scientifically done analysis
of the headlines as they're actually
written rather than butchering them and
then claiming that because i think i
just got to point out real quick um
i had to frantically click away from the
onion because back in 2000 they had a
racial slur on their front page for like
four days as part of one of their
realities yeah
maybe they were a bit more edgy back
then i don't know i was like oh we can't
show that it was the wild west for
better or worse i do think i don't think
that it's bad these days like i don't
people call it a dystopian stuff i just
think it's always been this crazy and
now the the curtains been pulled back
and we can see the inner workings of the
beast
i think that when they are accusing you
of basically hollowing this out and
using it as a skin suit all they're
doing is projecting because this is what
we see them doing with every single
institution they touch that's all they
ever do and they're talking about how
you're like conveying a political
message but trying to do it with comedy
they're trying and failing to do this
with people like colbert and the onion
they're doing it incredibly poorly
because they have no self-reflection
they have no humility they can never be
wrong and those are things that are
required you need to be able to make fun
of yourself because you know if you make
fun of yourself you'll never run out of
material they cannot do it but they're
trying i think they're really jealous of
what you're doing at the babylon bee
that's kind of awesome well i think you
undermine them yeah they did they'd
actually make fun of us a little bit
they were kind of like without naming us
you know they were they were making
jokes about how they'd been suspended on
twitter and this is their last tweet you
know like or they they can no longer
tweet and they're tweeting that you know
so they were kind of like ironically
like tweet what's the joke the joke was
that we were i guess like
putting it on that we were being
suppressed or but we still are on
twitter and we can still tweet if we
want to or something like that the joke
was that we're faking it i don't know
it wasn't really abundantly clear it
wasn't abundantly clear and no one got
it because no one knew what they were
referring to exactly their audience has
no familiarity with what's going on with
us right and twitter so it's just kind
of like it got no engagement no reaction
yeah well and so lydia you made a really
good point about projection and this is
something i kind of want to talk about
for a moment here when
i write a joke
or someone pitches a joke to me for
freedom tunes or i write a rough concept
that i want to shop around to friends
nobody goes i like the political point
you're making you should make that one
it's like if they'll either go i don't
like that wonder oh that's funny you
should do it right so people will still
discern whether something is funny or
not even if they agree with it
politically and i know you know i've
spoken with people at babylon b who have
told me that you know the headlines will
get shot down all the time and then you
try to come up with the one that's
funniest and so what they don't realize
is when we're writing jokes we're not
sitting down going how are we going to
get them like how are we going to get
the other side it's just something comes
to your mind that you think is funny and
then you end up producing it but that's
not how they
write their humor oh and that's by the
way they think we're doing what they're
doing real quick i just pulled up the
babylon b and the first thing i see is
nancy pelosi recommends avoiding paint
at the pump by becoming a millionaire
through insider training
that's really good
and even the left should find that funny
everyone knows nancy pelosi is like that
pelosi stock tracker january 6 the
musical i need to watch this oh my gosh
yeah did you
oh are you well what i was going to say
is you know the the only really the only
consideration when you're when you're
writing a headline you're pitching a
headline is
is is it funny you know it's not like oh
does it make the point that we want to
make well that's kind of really
secondary too is it funny it's got to be
funny first you got to lead with that
and where they want to get your head
because this is the criticism that we
have is that you know this we've engaged
in hateful conduct with the rachel
levine joke right
they want you thinking to yourself you
know am i making fun of someone who's
beneath me am i punching down at someone
who's marginalized and oppressed while
i'm privileged that person in a very
high position of government yeah the
white male high-ranking government
official am i punching down at that
person right but that's that's where
they want your head at they want you
thinking in those terms i'm like
i'm not
sexist or racist i don't think people
are beneath me like imagine thinking to
yourself imagine thinking to yourself
you know what
i shouldn't joke about those people
where they're beneath me
yeah so condescending like we should be
able to joke about each other
indiscriminately right so so you know
having to put your head in that space i
think is really unhealthy but that's
where their comedy writers are at
they're like oh i'm a white male with
privilege writing jokes i've got to be
very careful about all the people i
could be punching down at yeah i can't
stand it we're working on a video game
and in the video game characters can be
randomly generated as any race and
there's going to be a character
customization menu so we made the joke
like if we made an anti-racist mode that
took all of the left's ideology and
applied it to the racialization of the
characters in this game like it really
helps you understand just how racist
they are yeah like what
their view of people's race was applied
to a video game act actually quantified
the game would be banned the game would
be banned instantly because you'd be
like it'd be racist well the idea is
like if we removed the stereotypes or
inverted them it exposes just how racist
they really are like the idea that white
people are privileged and have all these
special benefits if you actually enacted
that in the game then characters based
on the cut the race you choose for your
character would have different stats
right away it's already like right they
jump higher not jump higher
i'm not going to get into how awfully
racist it would be but
we could not apply anti-racism to the
game because it's equally as racist as
being
just typically stereotypically racist
right and they want you to think of the
world in those terms when you're writing
jokes it's like well you know can't
joke about women women are beneath me
they're beneath me on the power
structure because i'm a man it's like
come on you know yeah i got pushed to
think that i was better than other
people because of my skin color it was
disgusting i don't know how to defend or
even to respond to that like i see
people's eyeballs we're like brains
floating in meat sacks i don't know
obviously skin tone has some value they
literally will say to you though they're
like ian accepted as a white person you
are better than other people why don't
you do it right like no
people and i'm not going to stop helping
a certain kind of person or like a
certain color person or a certain height
of person i'm not going to stop but
it's like how are we punching down by
the way making jokes like you mentioned
this is a high-ranking government
official or whatever but but these ideas
that we make fun of you know if we're
making fun of um
you know progressive gender ideology you
know that's coming from from all the
biggest corporations the universities
the government officials um you know
it's coming from everywhere media and
entertainment it's being
shoved down your throat from the top
down
and god forbid you make a joke about it
you're punching down on the marginalized
and the oppressed if people can like
silence you and punish you and
de-platform you from merely joking about
them
do they really lack power are they
really marginalized are you really in a
position of power over them i don't
think so you have to actually control
what you say in order to not be punished
by them they're in the they're the ones
in the position of power in that
situation that's a good question what's
that quote if you want to know who holds
the power in society look at to who you
can't criticize that was the nazi who
said that what was that
it was it was a neo-nazi who wrote that
well it's true yeah
and i think it's a really bad quote too
because like
the idea that because you can't
criticize someone means they have power
over you is just not true either
but what that's literally i think that
is does indicate that how do you think
it doesn't like a a disabled uh person
like a a child with leukemia doesn't
have any power over your life ian but
you can't criticize them like it's not
it's not okay to go out there smack
talking a bunch of like like
it is okay a child who's dying of cancer
you don't criticize them because it's
just like not cool but if you're part of
a protected group and everyone is going
to come to your defense and make sure
that you don't have a job anymore if you
make fun of someone who's in that
protected group then that then them with
that group at their back they have all
the power but it's a political faction
not the not the victim group they're
they're using you know what i mean
you're saying cancel culture see there's
actually a voltage
yeah yeah because people are trying to
to i can't stand this this this stuff
they do because they're trying to talk
about the jews and they and they try to
manipulate their way into getting people
like you ian to use their quotes well
ask
we as a society don't like it when you
criticize the dead they're recently
deceased we like to go to funerals and
be like the dead person has no power
over you but you can't criticize them
okay they're not alive you say living
people sure a child who's a burn victim
saying like that was a disgusting thing
you just that people are going to be
like dude you need to chill out yeah but
the kid can't do anything to you it's
the people if you criticize someone
political faction other people that
cancel culture will raise up but if you
criticize someone to their face and and
something bad can happen to you that
means that they have some sort of power
over you i do think that it's true that
when people get into power they become
very sensitive and touchy um you know
there's a reason there's a court jester
making fun of the king you know it's the
people in in power bristle at being
mocked they can't bear to be mocked they
can't bear to be ridiculed and so
they're very likely especially the more
authoritarian they lean they're more
likely to clamp down on speech to
prevent that so they don't look bad i
mean look at north korea for example you
know you you can't make certain jokes
and you have to call him dear leader you
can't even just call him kim jong-un i
mean you gotta call him the dear leader
exactly you're not on a first name basis
cam the dear leader i call him moon
personally but yeah he's just a party
so it's one of the exercises of power
one of the exercises of power is to make
sure that people can't criticize you
it's to retain the power by shielding
yourself from criticism and mockery and
so i think there's legitimacy to it from
that from that angle at least i think
you know when it comes to the us and it
comes censorship
there's they don't have power over us
they they control the systems they
control and we've given them the power
because we use their systems we adhere
to it but look at what's been happening
over the past few years
but a lot of companies tried launching
and the machine tried crushing them gab
was was you know smacked around a bit by
the big tech companies but in the end
they couldn't win and now you've got
rumble is taking off massive support
because finally there are people who are
just like i can't take it anymore so
rumble's doing cloud infrastructure
they're supporting truth social which is
massive engagement you've got the rumble
video player you've got the launch of
parallel economy payment processing
services it's all starting to happen is
this an ad are we doing an ad read now
are we no
just but it is happening when you say
that we've given them power i agree with
that i mean when people ask me like well
you know
you you talk about speaking boldly
speaking the truth boldly whatever you
know saying what you think uh what if i
do that and i lose my job i'm like well
why do you think you'd lose your job
because you'd be an outlier if you spoke
your mind right well why why are you an
outlier well because everyone else is
self-censoring everyone else is
self-centered you probably work in a
company where half the people agree with
you but they're afraid to speak their
mind and i said i think when we
self-censor we're doing the tyrants work
for him and giving them power they
shouldn't have
you know i've always
i just man for whatever reason
cared substantially less than other
people i remember when i was working for
the abc company i would just like say it
somebody would have like something on
their desk like oh that's wrong by the
way and they'd be like oh and i'd be
like here let me show you and i'd like
here's why your feminist weird pay gap
thing is not true
and they'll get really angry about it
there's a value to discerning to know
when to speak like because if if you're
the only one that stands up and says it
you might get the hammer come down but
if you can coordinate a bunch of people
to rise uprise you know then you get
like a letter to the editor from like 60
people will sign it and it's like i
can't i can't afford to lose my
employees
what's that breitbart quote about the
fire
i don't know i remember exactly what he
said
he doesn't like walk towards the fire i
can't remember exactly what he said but
someone either like
created a derivative version of it and
it was something like
you know people are scared they see the
fire they're scared they're told if you
go near it'll burn you but then those
who are actually brave enough to jump
through it see on the other side as
freedom says walk toward the fire don't
worry about what they call you all those
things are set against you because they
want you to stop in your tracks but if
you keep going you're sending a message
to the people who are rooting for you
you're agree who are agreeing with you
the message is that they can do it too
and also if you stop and stand in a fire
you get burned but if you run through it
you're not gonna feel the heat that
that's what i i was talking with someone
about it and i somebody else i was
talking to took that quote and the
version they said to me was basically
like you know we all see this fire and
we know it burns we know it's scary so
everyone's just staying back from it but
they're being singed by the heat some
people are brave enough to run towards
it jump through it on the other side as
a beach
people are celebrating having a good
time and so for me it was never hard
because
i just
people want to push this nonsense stuff
i just don't care like i've i've dealt
with hardship and i'm just like you
can't take anything from me you can fire
me you can boot me out what's my worst
case scenario i'm chilling man i'll go
skate skateboarders we've always just
wanted to hang out sleep under a tree
and go skate cram ourselves in a single
bedroom apartment so you got no leverage
here buddy
but
now like there's a community built being
built on the other side of that fire
there's the babylon bee there's new
infrastructure that's coming and if you
just say enough don't know don't care
you will be supported
uh james o'keefe
he gives jobs to the to the
whistleblowers he raises money for the
whistleblowers and people donate to the
whistleblowers they're not left high and
dry he keeps supporting to make sure
that they're not left holding an empty
bag and as this you know this faction or
whatever people who believe in freedom
keeps expanding growing and gaining more
power and access there's more
opportunity for more people to speak up
because you won't be left behind what do
you guys think about mean jokes
like comedy i guess i'll ask you
particularly because you're here seth
but like what do you think about like
the difference between jokes that are
like that have a but to the joke like a
person or a type of person versus like
other forms of comedy like you know a
funny saying or something
well i mean generally speaking like
what we do like
satirical comedy is meant to be
um
it's meant to make you laugh but also
make you think it's like it's more like
there's supposed to be some in some way
that it like cuts you makes you sting
but for a healing purpose right so it's
more like a surgeon's scalpel that's
like intended for the purpose of like
removing something bad so that it heals
better than it was to begin with like a
vaccine rather that yeah like a vaccine
there you go yeah for children
so like um
so
it's uh i i think that jokes are
generally
the idea that the jokes are because
we're often accused of being mean and
being cruel with our with our jokes and
well maybe you're looking at it the
wrong way you know like jokes
you can take it that way i guess you can
be offended by it you can get really
upset about it are you talking about a
joke that's just like you know calling
somebody fat or something like that
where there's no redemptive purpose to
it and it's not like whit metted to
moral concern or something like that
where where you're trying to like make a
point
i'm asking are you are you talking about
something that's just mean to be mean
spirited
yeah yeah or or let's go let's say what
you're saying like you use someone's
fault uh to make a greater point
um i personally i mean
i'm not really into like this guy's uh a
dog and here's why yeah it's like look
at all the five ugly things about that
guy and then people yeah watch it fall
down on a banana peel
no i see more i i see like a like
a moral reason to do comedy that is like
that attacks but
more ideas than people you know it's
like ridiculing bad ideas it's going
after them and trying to tear them down
so that they're not like
as appealing as they were and imagine
how much better off we'd be by the way
if more comedians were doing that you
have all these bad ideas that are
infecting children's minds
you know we've got all these we got like
high depression rates and suicide rates
and and and you know 10 year olds
transitioning and wanting to get on
puberty blocking hormones and all this
stuff imagine if comedians were doing a
better job mocking the insanity of all
of this and making it less appealing
instead you've got everybody promoting
this stuff like it's great and you're
not even allowed to make fun of it or
it's hate speech
comedy can play a role in that kind of
stuff
by mocking bad ideas that are harmful
for someone i want to show you this
we'll pull this video real quick i'm not
going to play the video but this is a
video called open mic uh open night it
used to be called overnight massacre
open mic now it's called open mic night
becomes a massacre when liberal arts
hecklers take over
this caused chaos at fusion
so this is several years old several
years old this 2015 and this is back
when i worked for fusion
this came out and i said this is one of
your your best videos because i was
talking to the the higher-ups and how
they can get their videos to get more
traffic because they were struggling and
i was like this one's big basically it's
a stand-up comedian no matter what he
says they boo him and call him racist or
offensive and then he's like no i feel
like i can't say anything and they're
like no it's a free speech zone and then
they boom and throw tomatoes at them
this one
pissed off the entire staff they said it
was racist and then the higher ups were
like why did we make a video insulting
our audience and then i was like dude
you guys it's like the only funny video
you have right then they start they did
eventually go on to make um celebrity
mockery videos which also was just like
general pop culture humor which was fine
but at the time this was relevant
politically savvy and it was funny and
it got half a million views in a couple
days and i was like it's because it's
good and people like it and it's funny
and they were like no nope it's
insulting our audience we can't have
that
ian you were sort of asking this
question about making fun of people and
it's it's honestly a good one because
it's something i've wrestled with too
um and i would tend to agree with you
that you want to attack
ideas more so i do think sometimes
there's still room to make fun of people
but i find that what tends to be most
cruel about our society is what we
choose to affirm rather than what we
choose to ridicule so we will let people
believe that they're capable of doing
something they're not capable of and
then just watch them get hurt and i
think i think that's a lot more cruel
than just being blunt with them and
saying no absolutely not you can't do
that oh be oh
well yeah so i mean for example we've
talked about this before but
on american idol what they would often
do is tell someone who couldn't sing at
all that they were a wonderful performer
and that they should sing in front of
the judges and then they would and it
would be unbelievably humiliating for
them they wouldn't they wouldn't tell
them you're the best they would say but
they would pass them on to the next
round even though they knew that you
couldn't sing now now now what would be
no i'm not saying if you knew that
person personally the best approach
would be to make fun of them like i
think it's it's a case-by-case basis
whether humor is the best approach but i
think it would be less cruel if someone
came to you in saying that way to poke a
little fun at them than to say oh no
you're great go on live television and
sing in front of everyone but our
society is really committed to doing the
latter and virtually all circumstances
where you encounter that problem it's
the exact same reason why somebody will
have spinach stuck in their teeth and no
one will tell them oh you gotta tell
them tell them yeah i mean i never
understood that i never i never
understood that i see someone and they
got like a thing on the table hey you
got some on your teeth oh thanks tell
anyone yeah like but people don't want
to do it they're like i'm not gonna say
anything yeah shout out to will uh he
was on chamberlain and i think he had
chocolate on his face and i was like i
didn't notice the cut on his face i
didn't know so i didn't say anything but
sorry will next time i'll call it out it
was like chocolate
one of the things you i was thinking
about when you're talking is obesity
because people used to tell fat jokes
and that's like
i think obesity isn't the person it's
the idea it's the behavior that you can
eat whatever you want and that you don't
have to fast and that you can eat sugar
and that fats bad sugars so it's these
ideas you can poke fun at the ideas
maybe not
at the person by name and showing their
body but i mean
you know how do you poke fun at the idea
of obesity without
showing someone i mean you could have a
computer generated
good comedians make fun of themselves
you know you had like you know chris
farley would make jokes at his own
expense all the time you know
fat guy in a little coat right you know
and and it's funny and he's willing to
laugh at himself about it and we've lost
that we've lost that ability to be able
to say you know what i'm not perfect
there are actually things about me that
are worth making fun of and laughing
about and they're flaws and it's okay to
recognize them as flaws and like laugh
about it and have a sense of humor about
it rather than being so uptight like oh
if someone makes fun of my physical
appearance you know
i'm distraught
i'm destroyed and i can never recover
from that you know we're by creating
safe spaces we're harming people by
never exposing them to even jokes
that like confront them with their flaws
i think the uh one of the big splits
that happens in the uh in the culture
war between left and right has a lot to
do with participation trophy parents
versus
parents who didn't do that right so it
feels like one of the big things that
divides left and right the left they're
entitled but they're also very soft they
need safe spaces trigger warnings when
someone says a mean word they think it's
violence because quite literally they've
never been insulted before i mean
imagine this you grow up in a in a town
or whatever with participation trophy
parents
snow plow parents who who bulldoze every
obstacle no one's allowed to say mean
words you've never been insulted in your
life let alone never had someone flick
your ear all of a sudden now you're an
adult you go on twitter and someone goes
you're dumb and they go
it's the first time i've ever felt this
pain why are you calling me dumb it's
like i've been spit on and shut it at
the same time yeah i don't think it's an
argument for you know bullying and
meanness so cruelness are
are good things it's more of an argument
that like
you don't build resilience of character
if you don't face challenges and you're
not like
and you're not having to deal with the
fact that you know you're not perfect
and not everybody's gonna be nice to you
you know and you can't expect that
everybody's gonna be nice to you and you
can't require that everyone treat you
perfectly in order for you to be like
healthy mentally like that's not that's
not a good place for anybody to be
especially kids it's ego
yeah but i think also
just just going back to the question
because we're talking about obesity here
um and you asked about using humor with
that i think
i i think the approach is
using humor like you said to kind of
toughen people up can work but then it
can have the the reverse effect so for
example if you have somebody claiming
you're healthy at all sizes that's just
ridiculous and you need to make fun of
it because if people believe that
they're going to end up indulging in
foods they shouldn't eat they'll get
overweight and then they'll never lose
the weight because they'll be able to
justify to themselves right they'll end
up being miserable so i think it's very
good to make fun of that idea but then
like pointing at a specific person who's
overweight and just ripping on them for
being overweight well they're probably
not going to lose weight if you do that
because you're reinforcing in their mind
this idea that like they're just fat and
gross indeed it's actually a good
example to bring that up because look at
all these shows like eric cartman in
south park or homer simpson or peter
griffin you know like the punch line and
there's a punch line in every episode
that has to do with their weight right
like phys their physical characteristics
um and it's and it's funny you know the
jokes about homer eats doughnuts all the
time you know he's lazy he sleeps at his
workstation
when he had that he's like the drinking
bird hitting the y on the keyboard right
that was great he's the villain i
actually tweeted that out homer
simpson's a villain and people were like
no no it's like dude don't use that as a
role model that guy beat his kid he's
severely overweight severely abusive
over and over again bart you know is a
devastation because of his poor
parenting yeah you know blame homer
that's true i blame a but i blame homer
yeah the the i think the worst cartoon
character is probably peggy hill you
ever watch king of the hill
that that woman is a sociopath like
textbook like narcissistic sociopath the
way she like neglects her family and is
and is very like she doesn't hear what
people are saying she's got to be on
some psychoactive crap like pros some
sort of
character i don't know
because she's not there she's not
emotionally available she's always like
just okay she doesn't speak spanish but
claims she does like she's like a
narcissistic borderline personality
disorder historian whatever
yeah crazy but yeah you make a good
point uh homer would strangle his son
and his son was uh would lash out and
and act you know inappropriately and
it's probably because his dad beat him
it was probably because his father's an
alcoholic
oh yeah but it's so funny because like
the fact that homer's like i love the
simpsons by the way i love the early
seasons but the fact that he's like
literally an alcoholic is just played
for life and i don't think he's ever
called an alcoholic really right but
it's just like no the man is literally
an alcoholic who beats his child
who falls asleep at the end of the
episode you root for him it's like this
is so genuinely no frank grimes didn't
no that's true frank grimes is the one
character with any sense on the shelf
and that's why he's grabbing the power
cables do you remember that one he's
like i don't need to wear gloves i'm
home or something really dark episodes
yeah
yeah that's show man yeah but early
early episodes they were edgy it was
funny
and that's part of the point too like
part of the point is homer is terrible
like that's part of the joke isn't it
interesting how shows back in the day
were like a wholesome family dealing
with like you know cha issues with their
kid growing up and then slowly over time
shows became more and more dysfunctional
mm-hmm then you ended up like married
with children which was one of the most
i think it was the highest rated sitcom
at the time we weren't going to watch
that was about the same time that the
simpsons came on too it was early late
80s yeah yeah late 80s i i really really
despised made with children because i
couldn't stand the fact that they were
all just awful people yeah but more
importantly was that uh al lost
everything like he would always lose and
i'm like i just i want to you know i
want to root for someone but i guess the
idea is a bad person so he doesn't
deserve it or something
yeah i thought peggy was good she was an
idiot but like is it because she kept
like just supporting al's doofusness
that she was also you know
there's one episode i liked and it was
where
finally like al bundy punches a guy and
then it ends with him saying they won a
lawsuit him with peggy they're loving
and laughing with each other and he says
i sued him for hurting my fist on his
face
and like i guess the point was it's
always backwards or something but that
was the one where i was like he won and
his wife loved him and i was like that's
the one i can remember all the rest of
them are just like the family hates
everybody hates each other and i don't
know i wouldn't want to watch it well we
see this a lot but there's a lot of
comedy that just gets way too
mean-spirited and the characters all
hate each other there's this joke that
basically every television show does
because they think it's like edging
interesting but almost all of these
shows have moments where like for a gag
one of the characters like ends up
betraying another character who they're
supposed to be friends with or who's a
family member it's like okay that was
like somewhat funny for that one joke
but you've totally undermined the
relationship between the characters
and so many shows are like willing to
sell out character development like that
for a punchline right you know what show
is actually really good though is it's
always sunny oh yeah there those people
are just deeply narcissistic and just
very very bad people and it's great
i haven't i haven't watched the later
episodes though but uh you know earlier
seasons were just absolutely fantastic
well and i wonder if they just keep
ramping it up right because that's kind
of what people would say about seinfeld
like in seinfeld they're all really bad
and it's always sunny takes it to the
next level and then who knows five ten
years from now it's going to be even
more insane and evil how do you get more
interesting
yeah like the episode where they're
going to be crack addicts i'm sure they
say they said the same thing about
seinfeld at the time like how do you get
worse than airline food man how are we
going to be you know
how are we going to
get past that
yeah
but now it feels like modern shows are
getting scared of being that edgy you
know what i mean like it's always dark
in philadelphia and then it would be
like just showing the street violence
right now
yeah it's not funny didn't it's always
sunny remove some episodes or something
i don't know yeah they remove some
offensive episodes well another so
there's another thing that happens too
it's an interesting phenomenon media but
when the economy is doing poorly comedy
tends to be more popular
because people want an escape they want
something funny and
so i i also wonder if maybe dark comedy
becomes more popular when things are
going well but when things are difficult
people don't want dark comedy as much
because they're already seeing some of
the bleakness of reality yeah that's why
i don't watch horror movies because
reality is horrifying enough when i
think about the economy and horror
movies my [ __ ] is my favorite genre but
it's just been lacking it's terrible
yeah they've just
i loved the campy b horror movies of the
80s i like dr sleep
that was great
that's a sequel right yeah what was the
sequel for shining the shining yeah yeah
that was that was pretty good stephen
king's kind of a weird guy though he
writes about like
kids in uh in really creepy
ways you weren't so creepy
that's a weird thing i don't think
people understand that there was a joke
in uh american dad where they find a
script for the fast and the furious or
something and then they realize that in
it there's a bunch of like gay erotica
and so they take it out and they're like
that can't be in there and then they
bring it to the studio and they're like
oh great hey wait a minute where's the
gay erotica they're like normally that's
supposed to be in there and they're like
what
so
this i think that's a play on stephen
king because a bunch of his books and
stories there's like really bad stuff in
there and they're like this is a great
story let's take that really offensive
and the story is i think maybe you've
not told me that yes yes geez well i'm
not talking about it online but that's
uh he writes a grafted a graphic section
about children doing adult things we'll
put it and for no reason just right
literally he's like i'm now going to
write this and it's going to be in the
book and you're like why why is that
also knocking he also literally wrote a
story that's just about a dude recalling
uh no good bad things happening to him
and and in extreme detail like wow
that's what i had a stephen king book
because i i when secret window came out
i was like i liked it and then i was
like i mean just i i heard that the
story was actually a little different so
i got the book that had the collection
in it and i'm like start reading it then
i just threw the book and i was like
whoa
what is wrong with that man
yeah like he he it's twisted horror they
say horror it's okay like violence is
fine uh nudity fine but as soon as it's
like graphic sex on kids yeah not fine
still horrifying but not it's a little
too close to home what is it because
they think it's brainwashing people and
making them more towards that like a
horror movies horror movies making
people more
violent
i don't know i mean there's you could
definitely have a debate about whether
or not that's healthy entertainment i
guess even with just straight horror
movies though i mean i've never it's
never been my favorite genre i always
just feel weird watching people like you
know for entertainment like slaughter
each other yeah i don't know like if
it's a context like war if it's
braveheart you know and they're like
carving each other up on the battlefield
it's different than like
a chainsaw massacre yes okay so and
that's a really important point right
context matter so in band of brothers
there's a lot of violence but there has
to be because they're trying to give you
an accurate depiction of the second
world war right right that's not the
same as we're just gonna have gratuitous
violence because we love violence we're
gonna go to super chats if you have not
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and
share the show with your friends head
over to timcast.com and become a member
because we're gonna have that uh not so
family-friendly uncensored episode
coming up at 11 p.m tonight
now we will read your super chats
danabus x says encourage your followers
to contact their senators to attach an
amendment to repeal the hughes amendment
to the new gun control bill what does
that one do what's the use amendment
how about every single person just calls
your senator or congressman
nonstop saying do not sign on to this
bill
don't organize at a time a specific time
on a specific day and then repeat that
it's super powerful
can you call them personally like
like if you called their personal is
that i doubt it i think you can only
call their office i mean it might be
considered harassment if you call their
home phone or something would it be
i would feel like i'm getting harassed
if people are calling my home phone
joshua harrison says leftists just
stormed the wisconsin state capitol over
abortion rights never forget 622. that's
right i saw that never saw that
[Music]
they went inside
yeah filled it up yep it was an
insurrection yeah actually
yeah
uh um 529 yeah do you know you remember
the 529 insurrection you didn't forget
did you didn't forget 5 29. that's right
after never forget falcon laser says get
tulsi gabbard on after the mines
festival uh i'll ask uh we're gonna be
on a panel together yeah if you guys
didn't know
uh this saturday in new york city
festival.mines.com
we're going to be uh speaking it's gonna
be a really awesome event and i'm gonna
be on a panel i think i think it's tulsi
right i think james o'keefe tulsi me ben
burgess
and uh it's gonna be comedy it's gonna
be great there's gonna be some stand-up
going to be a lot of people there uh
seth you're gonna be there i think i'll
be there too that's right it's a great
lineup yeah it's it's it's a big theater
it's a nice venue yeah in new york yeah
festival.minds.com get your tickets and
there's even like a free ticket form if
you if you're if you're hurt and you
really want to go because we want to get
people to show up
all right let's see what we got
okay
rogaldorn says why not just recall the
rhinos get him out of office senators
can't be recalled sorry they get in for
six years they sit there and then they
just spit in your face yup
the k
the kl tanker says went to buy my first
handgun in california today wearing my
inflation is theft shirt i'm gonna go
back tomorrow to use the range and
officially buy it thinking about wearing
my if you trust the government shirt we
are change.org very good shirts by the
way
all right smokey joe says hey tim nearly
everyone accepts accepts some degree of
limits on speech including you and i so
how do you rationalize being a two-way
absolutist while being a 1a relativist
appreciate y'all love you sheamus
because the first amendment first of all
it covers a variety of things and we're
trying to understand what it means that
the uh
the right to free speech shall not be
infringed right what is free speech
referring to
the expression of your ideas and
politics should not be infringed by the
government that doesn't mean you can
orchestrate crime
that's that's that's that's
not now there's a challenge there and
i've brought this up
because if the government just makes
certain things crimes then they can
continually infringe upon your right to
express your political opinions so i've
often said i'm not entirely sure there
can be limits on free speech in that
case and perhaps as many other first uh
1a absolutists or free speech episodes
have said only the direct action itself
should be the crime
there's a good point there as for the
right to keep and bear arms it says the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms it exists there it is and arms
refers to the same weapons the
government has that's it we know exactly
what they mean we know what they meant
when they wrote it the dip so the issue
i suppose is they're two different
things
i don't know you guys have thoughts on
that yeah thinking of speech and action
the difference between like they go no
it's only illegal if you do the action
speech is a form of action it requires
you to make your body act to make the
speech and then if you record it
especially that's some big action so
it's you know you can definitely
you can definitely
speak things you know that's a form i
think one way to put it is
there are questions around the legality
of orchestrating crime
you know being the person who provides
the mental capacity for a crime to be
carried out some people have the brute
force and the strength or the
willingness to take action physical
action against another person but not
the wherewithal or mental capacity and
then you serving as a vehicle to drive
people or enable them to do it there's a
question there keeping a gun you've
committed no crime the fact that i have
a gun does not hurt anybody does not
infringe on anyone else's rights it is
not a threat to anybody i have done
nothing wrong and what context are we
talking about free speech rights though
are we talking about them on like
youtube social media
you know the constitution can the
government infringe upon yeah i think
that's a great question because on
youtube i don't i think of this a lot
like daily what's free speech on youtube
youtube's corporation they can shut down
anyone at any time that's per and if the
government's to come in and say no
corporation you got to do what we say
well that's kind of fascist of our
government to get involved
so like i'm like what does it mean what
does free speech on the internet even
mean
with private companies
owning the place there's been like there
was a supreme court justice back in an
old case going way back in like it was
marsh versus alabama it had to do with
like this company town and it was a
privately owned company town and the
question was whether or not you had free
speech rights in this town because it's
owned by corporation
um and they said yes and they said yes
it you do have free speech there because
the town is performing all the functions
that the government normally would and
so no one's really been successful in
taking that argument and moving it to
like social media but one of the
opinions in that one of the justices
justice black wrote something about how
the more you open up
uh as a private person the more you open
up your property or your business to the
public
the more
you cons you you kind of give up some of
your rights to allow for some of theirs
to flourish so they have their own
rights both statutory rights and
constitutional rights
and you're allowing them on your
platform your property or whatever and
so places of public accommodation have
to accommodate the statutory and
constitutional rights of the people that
are there yeah that's one of the
arguments that was made in that case in
particular and i don't see any reason
why that shouldn't apply to social media
companies occupy wall street famously
had a lawsuit uh
many people were like it's zuccotti park
is private property and then there was a
lawsuit and the courts were like but
it's open to the public so protest is
allowed and then they couldn't evict the
protesters they eventually evicted the
protesters on sanitation grounds or
something like that but this is why the
chase plaza about a block away shut down
to the public because they didn't want
occupy wall street taking over their
public plaza privately owned right the
occupiers also went beneath the deutsche
bank building which was another
privately owned public space because
they knew they were legally allowed to
now occupy these spaces that's how it
works i see twitter as being no
different
all right
gadsden says tim you talk about national
divorce civil war all the time i wrote a
book about exactly that can i send a
copy of it to your po box yes it's
called national divorce a practical plan
to prevent civil war it's available on
amazon as well interesting very cool we
have paused the fan mail uh
for the time being i'm not sure if
sending some of the po box will get
through or not but you're welcome to
send it
all right
butter warrior says tim thank you for
being liberal for i am conservative
sheamus thank you for being pious for i
am on the road and my jesus looking man
i drank gin and tonic and i had
clairvoyance my gal stay you oh well all
right i like that sweet
you denton says sheamus got it even
liberals don't believe these
common-sense gun laws will solve
anything it's all incremental steps
towards a gun-free utopia yeah and don't
you think don't you think it should be
mandated if you're trying to push for
legislation after tragedy to explain how
that legislation would have prevented
what just happened right but they don't
because that's not their goal it's their
goal is to get your guns it'll affect
law-abiding people
and there were already laws in place
that should have stopped that from
happening that didn't that didn't
exactly
all right miner says tim i've i've been
wondering for a while why don't you use
music at the start when the show goes
live it would give an audible clue that
it started
sure
good idea yeah for a while we were just
we would just go live and then you know
go live but then youtube auto plays an
ad for a lot of people so then many
people would miss like the first 30
seconds so now we wait a minute yeah so
we can we can do that i suppose
jason takes says my wife had our second
daughter this morning named her lydia in
part because of how sweet and awesome
sour patch lids is
well you're the only she knew how you
really were oh my god okay
that makes me so happy that's adorable
congratulations
is wonderful though russell says you
need to push for a recall for all these
rhinos tim let's not wait and for the
next election senators can't be recalled
how amazing is that members of congress
can so great and should be
so all those congress people are voting
for this stuff recall
all right
friedrich frederick friedrich borman
says hello tim and crew i'm once again
asking you to invite russian libertarian
mikhail svetov you can reach him on
twitter at amsvetov he's very
knowledgeable and knows a whole lot
about american politics
interesting is he in america i'll have
to check him out
a06 says tim could you look up the court
case
coniglia v strom the supreme court
already voted on it in a 9-0 decision
and it supposedly might already refute
red flag laws interesting really when
was that
let's take a look into it
all right jd russell says i've enjoyed
the previous theological discussions on
the members only show you guys should
have on joel richardson author of the
islamic antichrist he would bring a
unique perspective on current events and
biblical prophecy interesting
you guys at the babylon beach should
probably just publish lottery numbers at
this point
which would be like sooner or later
was that a comment did you just read
that card no no i'm just saying the
babylon b who published lottery numbers
you know the guys of satire i'll say it
right now right here if you become a
premium subscriber today we'll publish
lottery numbers just for you premium
subscribers only got to sign up
we'll give you the fortune the fortune
numbers
all right nate woltering says tim you
moved to the middle of nowhere in west
virginia yet you compare the weather of
miami to west virginia dude florida's so
much bigger than miami lol
yeah
like all of florida is hot though i know
miami is like particularly bad
yeah like west virginia it's just you
get seasons you know
72 the other night it was just the
perfect perfect we had like three days
you know just do what the snowbirds do
they come down they're there when it's
like cool and nice and then they leave
for the summer and escape yeah yeah they
went north they go to the mountains they
go somewhere else so basically what luke
does yeah yeah he like shows up and i
was like i wonder why he's back and it's
like he's migrating yeah you know he's
got migratory bird yeah it's true fly
south for the winter
all right let's grab some more of these
super chats
nate woodsworth woodworth says joni
ernst is my senator i'm 24. she was the
first senator i ever voted for i'm so
mad i'm looking into how what i need to
run against her and i will yes bravo
absolutely
western canadian commentary says tim you
keep saying it's a choice between trump
or desantis but why not both give trump
second term in 24 then to sanderson 28
let trump drain the swamp then desantis
brings america into a golden age keep it
the great work i i agree a trumpet
santa's ticket i don't know what do you
think um
would they work together would they not
would they want that you know they got
to be on board with that i don't know
yeah i have no idea how they have been
like photographed at events together
like in recent times i guess so i'm
thinking it's going to be desantis
yeah because i like predict it has
desantis winning right now some polls
are coming out and well and i think
there are good reasons for that right
regardless of whether you want to
attribute this to you know the deep
state stopping trump or the political
establishment not letting him do what he
needed to do we have seen desantis
effectively govern after covet hit and
after the left tried shutting the entire
economy down and started writing and all
the shenanigans they've been up to
we we really haven't seen the same from
trump he's been gone and when he was in
office he wasn't able to achieve the
things he wanted to in those
circumstances whereas desantis has been
able to i'm not saying it's the same
scenario but i am saying it's reasonable
that people would be more trusting of
desantis after that
brand new clown world says a simple
thing i do in terms of culture jamming
as making stickers all it takes is vinyl
sticker paper and a cheap cheap inkajet
printer i go to my local skate park or
dive bar and slap on a bare shelf biden
or one nation controlled by the media
sticker
ah yes yes
yeah we had uh uh we got criticized some
some leftist outlet because we have
proof of gun uh stickers i love it where
it's like the proof of vaccination card
yeah but it says proof of gun and then
it's like write down what gun you had
and they were like yes fake gun gun uh
declaration forms or whatever it's like
yeah someone's real likely to think
that's real
and i don't i don't know about that they
just thought it was like how dare you oh
whatever
colby browns is tim bravo putting west
virginia senator on blast don't forget
mcconnell giving in on the debt ceiling
and infrastructure leading to inflation
this blow up the phone uh this blow up
the phone lines and let them know what
you think
yes
but i've i've mitch mcconnell is awful
we need better leadership the republican
party is the republican party a bunch of
new
populist libertarian types came into the
republican party because of uh donald
trump and now many of them are just like
i can't believe mitch mcconnell would do
this to us
i don't understand why someone like
desantis doesn't like
inspire more people to like have a
backbone like him you know to stand like
look at the response you know we're he's
in a conversation right now and he's
he's ahead he's head-to-head or ahead in
polls against trump for like running for
president well why because he hasn't
like been spineless and rolled over and
let the left just do whatever you know
like he stands up to them i just don't
see how that's not like
replicated why is nobody saying why why
do people on the right why do
republicans think that the best thing to
do is appease the left when obviously
what desantis is doing is working yeah
yeah exactly and it's not even just a
question of what desantis is doing
working though it obviously does how can
you a see what desantis is doing and b
see what like mitch mcconnell and mitt
romney are doing and golly yeah you know
what i'm gonna be like
those guys
right yeah right
yeah i mean you've got right now
unpredicted desantis is beating trump
and if you've got this narrative that
trump controls the party but the santa's
starting to pull ahead in the polls
clearly he's doing something right right
these these republicans should be like
as you as you said amylate
emulate desantis to win right exactly
well you know maybe they're just not
smart people huh how about that
all right the one free man says tim
there are a lot of wealthy people not
doing anything uh wait there are a lot
of wealthy people not doing anything
klaus schwab and soros hold our beer
that's right
yeah you see unfortunately all the rich
people are actually doing stuff and our
culture warriors are doing it and the
bad ways against us
yeah
like
it's cool that elon musk is gonna is
trying to buy twitter
but
it would not be difficult for him to
start a media organization or invest in
someone starting something
or to prop up uh
anyone challenging the narrative
he could uncancel people he could he
could be like i'm gonna hi i'm gonna
i'll give i'll put 10 million dollars
towards uh comedy comedy shows i will
guarantee that the industry exists
that that's what i'm talking about like
do that
we're talking about doing um
a new kind of award there's people doing
that by the way trying to uncancel daily
wires on cancelled some people
absolutely um you know i i came to the
aid of the libs of tick-tock girl who i
won't name here when she was being
doxxed and and taken out so the daily
water
they're building themselves up from the
ground up they're building this big
empire there are people who are already
on the top of these big towers who
purport to believe in a lot of the same
things who could snap their fingers and
they have resources yeah they don't do
it yeah you know
they do some stuff but i'll tell you one
of the things i've encountered is that a
lot of the people who actually have the
money don't understand cultural issues
and so they keep approaching things from
this tech perspective where they're like
you know look to be honest like even
buying twitter i think is great but i
think it shows the kind of it shows the
world view of elon musk the solution is
buying twitter well buying twitter is a
nuclear bomb in the culture war but the
issue is you need culture warriors to
create culture share culture and inspire
young people
owning twitter doesn't necessarily
change what's going on but at least
they'll be allowed to speak on his
platform when he's managing it so it is
good but i hear a lot from people
they're like if we just build this new
platform and i'm like that's not
changing the culture not changing the
fact that a large portion of millennials
believe these things you know well and
it also doesn't provide an alternative
in the sense that you're not going to
have people like the people that are on
twitter right now you have the full
diverse spectrum of like viewpoints
represented on twitter right now you
know you got people far left far right
and everybody in between and if you
build an alternative that's like if musk
were to start an alternative that was
like a free speech platform he's like
hey come join my free speech platform
how many people on the left are going to
join that platform do they want a free
speech platform where where there's no
where there's moderation but not for
what they consider misinformation or
hate speech
of course not
yeah i got i think you got it free i'm
not going to go near it the only way you
can really get free speech is let people
build their own networks with the code
it's
i'll explain it later
yeah jt says tim don't rent space on
billboards buy the billboard buy it put
up your message and leave it leave it up
forever
okay
but it's probably just not cost
effective
what if instead of billboards you put
shirts on people you know you just pay
people to wear your shirt that has your
message on it just line them up send
them out in large groups or something
find a homeless shelter nearby
charleston and give them like 500 shirts
of all different sizes of each like
there's 5 000 shirts and they're giving
away all these shirts that just say you
know
shelly is trash or whatever that'd be
hilarious
and then they're like but they're free
shirts and these people really need to
wear them it's like also there's home no
no no
you if if they're going to give it to
homeless people it's got to be something
like
more political about why are there
homeless people in this place in the
first place why is this place suffering
and then point to the senator who's
supposed to be doing right by the people
you know what i mean right right then
you're getting more political i guess
though you could be like it's their
fault i'm here wearing this shirt thank
them
bad leadership
all right mr devilman says ben franklin
was a boss while in england during the
war as a diplomat he hired his own
private fleet of pirates to hit english
supply ships
wow
that's crazy
well good for him i suppose
yeah
good for ben you know one of the things
by the way on the on the free speech
stuff in twitter and musk and all that
stuff one thing that i don't know if you
guys have talked about it much here but
i feel like it doesn't get talked enough
about enough
is the fact that these platforms like
twitter for example they give you all
the tools you need to decide who you're
going to listen to
like i can mute or block anybody i don't
have to see if you start saying stuff
that i don't like i can stop seeing it
without taking away your voice it's
about taking away your voice they want
to do yeah but but but it's like it's
it's just insane you're right it it
that's what it's about but if it's but
ultimately it's like the tools are there
for you to like ins if it's a if it was
really about having a safe space and not
being exposed to that stuff the tools
are there to protect yourself right now
so it has to be about taking away your
voice an issue i've had is if i mute
somebody and then someone responds to
them i see the response right and the
person i'm muted is tagged in it and i'm
like i don't want to think about that
person that's why i muted them so you
gotta go and fix that keep muting
everybody mute all the threads where
that name is popping up yeah it can
become an option
yeah all right ego
ego lit lister
the bee did a great article on our
church and baptizing via water slides
tim as a member i'm asking that you buy
up all the billboards love you all
awesome
baptizing by water slides a lot of
people thought that was real a lot
really yeah including one of our ploy
employees she now works for us but she
admitted when we hired her that she
originally thought that article was real
wow
well you know now snopes is sounding
convincing
[Laughter]
you need to be taken off the internet
yep
joe massinik says dead internet alexa
will soon be able to read stories as
your dead grandma techcrunch
yeah and i think i was reading that
facebook can take a person's profile and
then create an ai chat by
based on their life and knowledge and
talk to you like you know it's like your
grandpa dies that's so eerie
i'm a ghost and you'll be like whoa
that's what you'll say to him yeah it's
those algorithms that should be free
sounds like you're the ai
having that much manipulation over the
populace is like is irksome i think
that's the code that needs to be freed
yeah for people to have access to at
least to see what it's doing with the
the alexa comment though is that because
alexa's been listening so much is that
why it's able to well they were talking
about uh you can you can have a custom
alexa voice
because i guess it's just based on
hearing samples of someone speaking
alexa will be able to imitate their
voice who knows how well you know
they'll be able to do it or it will be
able to do it
that's weird yeah alicia z del valle
says i think louis ck said that he felt
we were actually closer as a society
when people mocked each other
about race and physical appearance in
general i thought that was kind of funny
lol
yeah i mean
arguably yes when people were doing
these jokes we weren't on the verge of
tearing each other apart and burning
everything to the ground right well i
think it's a chicken or egg style
question so
if you're not close with somebody and
they start making offensive jokes about
you you're going to be less likely to
laugh especially if they're an enemy and
there's been tension there but if you're
friends with somebody and they poke some
fun at you you're probably gonna laugh
they can get away with a lot more so i
think being able to joke about those
things is the sign of a very healthy
society because the people in the
society actually believe that the person
poking fun at them doesn't mean them any
harm today that's very clearly not the
case and i'm not sure if it's not the
case because we can't joke about it i
think it's probably the case just
because
tensions have been heightened for other
reasons but the the lack of humor is
certainly a symptom
all right dannabis x says the hughes
amendment banned the manufacture of
machine guns for civilian use in 1986 ah
that one yes yes we should get rid of
that yes
that's stupid
all right young jaws young jeff says
killer clowns from outer space that's
that is all i am that is all i am a
gorilla oh okay okay
let's see volcipheron herald of the
winter mist says article 1 section 27 of
the oregon constitution states the
people shall have the right to bear arms
for the defense of themselves and the
state but the military shall be kept in
strict subordination to the civil power
interesting wow
it's not going too well up there i
suppose
no
matthew gregor says check out saint
philip neri he literally hung out with
the dregs of italy making jokes that
were the punch uh
jokes that were where where the punch
line was their sin
oh i see what you're saying
the joke caused them to see the reality
of the life they were living
wow interesting interesting
amos moses says gotta move to oklahoma
we banned red flag laws two years ago
nebraska sounds pretty nice too so is
missouri yeah
yeah yep
all right nolan bus says vosh is
currently defending the position that
taking kids to drag shows is not bad on
alex stein's page this is madness bad is
good and good is bad
it's really funny seeing the left come
out and defend the drag uh queen story
hour thing and and it's like it's funny
because i saw this leftist journalist
post something being like can we can we
uh no no i think it was uh
yeah they said something like can we
make the distinction between
you know uh drag shows that are
stripping and drag queens just reading
books and i'm just like oh yeah because
having a go-go dancer read your kids
books is is fine like i'm pretty sure
parents would not be okay with that
either well i mean look 10 years ago if
someone was a drag queen during their
off time and they were let into a school
to read a book to children that would be
a controversy today they're doing it in
drag and you're told you have to accept
it what makes someone a queen like a
drag queen because if i put on a dress
i'd technically be in drag that's kind
of the definition
it's very specific like full costume
foam hips big makeup that's what makes
the queen the drag queen is when they
put on the makeup and stuff i guess i
mean it's like just
it's like what is the purpose you know
and they have they actually have a
stated purpose and for what they're
doing it's to like grow kids it's to uh
like
stimulate the queer imagination or
something like that in children and it's
like that's literally grooming and yeah
and this is all over public libraries
and schools and schools are signed on to
this stuff and i'm just thinking to
myself you know like
how do drag queens
whether it's inappropriate whatever it's
a man dressed as a woman it's always
that way you know it's always a man
dressed as a woman how does that do
anything but distract from story time
what's the point of storytelling
the drag queen like perform the argument
they made is that drag queens are in
costume and it's theatrics they're
reading a story in character right and
my my argument right back is like
drag shows
have a set standard of what they are it
is they walk around they take tips from
the audience it is comparable to go go
dancing
if we said go go dancing for kids
parents would be like excuse me we can
put a pole in the room too and they can
do that because the drag queens have
been doing the same kinds of dancing
they've done some of that yeah and
parents would probably be like hey wait
a minute but the left is jumping over
themselves to defend this because it's
tribal issues right but we'll uh we'll
if we'll leave it there if you haven't
already smash the like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends we're gonna have that members
only show up at about 11 p.m you're not
gonna want to miss it because we are
going it's it's uncensored not family
friendly we're we we record that right
now after the show and then it goes up
at 11. you can follow the show at tim
cast irl basically everywhere you can
follow me at tim cast seth do you want
to shout anything out
uh you can follow the babylon bee not on
twitter right now we're locked out but
hopefully if we get back you can follow
us there uh but we're still on facebook
instagram pablomb.com um
our youtube channel as well like and
subscribe there right on i just saw the
the video sheamus did with the babylon b
was hilarious
oh the one for the uh rod butcher's
debate tactics yeah
yeah yeah that one was that one was
hilarious thank you i i can only say
that because i can't take credit for all
the jokes um
so yeah i'm sheamus coughlin i have a
youtube channel called freedom tunes
i create political cartoons and we're
going to be releasing one tomorrow i
think you guys will enjoy if you want to
go over to freedomtunes.com
for five bucks a month you can become a
member and
you'll be supporting independent content
and getting an extra cartoon every week
guys i want to remind you about
festival.minds.com because i'm going to
be there speaking with blair white bill
ottman we're going to be talking about
internet the future of internet the
technology of internet
social media censorship all the above
it's going to be hot so check it out
festival.mines.com get a ticket there
it's going to be in new york city at the
beacon theater and it's this saturday
june 26th looking forward to seeing you
if you're you mentioned the free tickets
no no you can also get free tickets a
lot of people may be financially pinched
or if you just want some free ticks go
to festival.mines.com and you can sign
up for the free ticket form yeah i am
really looking forward to the mines
festival because i've never been to new
york city so this is going to be super
fun i'm excited seth's going to be
joining us there blair white's going to
be there tulsi gabbard's going to be
there it's going to be a really great
time i'm i'm super stoked about it we're
just going to drive up it's going to be
super rad you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com at sourpatchlids as
well as sourpatchlist.me
we will see you all at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye
you